Three,
what is that other thing that you have
saved their chunk.
That's John Mayer.
What is it?
John Mayer won't sue us.
He likes us.
You could play.
Let's start from scratch.
Why?
Because there can be three.
Three quarter was.
Oh,
okay.
Ready?
Go.
Do you open your shell with a.
your body is wonderland.
Yes.
My body is one.
Don't hate the Joe Rogan experience.
Take three folks.
This is a fucking ghetto podcast.
All right.
This is how we rock it plays the
gentlemen,
the one and only Eddie F dot.
Join us.
Ladies and gentlemen,
please give it up for Eddie.
F I F
tea.
You can find him on twitter.
He's a hilarious standup comedian and a
good pal of mine and we are sponsored by
the fleshlight.
Before we go any further,
go to Joe Rogan.net.
Click the link and type in the name
Rogan and you get 15 percent off.
It's fogging a fabulous masturbation to
have Mr.
Jeff,
I know you're not into those things.
You know you're a wholesome gentlemen.
You're not.
You're not the type of boy didn't go
dry.
You go drive.
I go drive high.
I feel like when I put lube on my hand
that I'm really committing to beating
off and it's like,
what's wrong with me?
I ain't even do dry dry.
I feel like I can just get in and get
out when I need to,
but when I do the flashlight,
you have to use a loop.
What did the flashlight.
Do they have like a celebrity vaginas
and parsley.
Do they've thought of it all?
Yeah,
they have alien vaginas.
Like blue ones will go to your Avatar
bitches,
but it's not avatar.
Of course.
It's alien as if his avatar that you
have to pay.
I hung out with the flashlight guy last
night.
I had a great time.
So a checklist.
Dow was cool.
Yeah.
If he's in town next week we're going to
get him.
He's.
He doesn't work for flush live anymore.
He quit.
He's opened up his own company.
Yeah,
that's right.
Did they have any like really,
really obscure,
like people like skewer porn stars?
I'm sure they do like weird.
I haven't looked through the catalog
that you can like even though I'm a part
of the company,
I have not looked through the catalog
and Luca,
you know,
like how I was flesh lighting with
Roseanne.
Barr's vagina.
Oh God.
I bet she would do it.
Roseanne would probably do it.
Bet Rosie O'donnell might do it too,
but there's a lot of lesbians.
It would do it just to throw someone's
out there using their vagina properly
with Rosie's,
you'd have to take two flashlights and
just rub them together.
Humana,
when Eddie,
you have to is also on a podcast called
you guys call it talking shit.
Just talking shit with Jim Jefferies and
Jim Jefferies and Eddie eft.
And recently you guys get fucked because
I guess you swore in your itunes.
Yeah,
just start title.
Like we ask for the episode.
We had one title once that was called
at.
I guess I'm going to have to eat this
dude's can't.
Was one of them.
A
guy named Brian Mccarthy told us a story
about how he fucked a postop
transsexual.
And uh,
he was telling the story about how she
told them she used to be a dude before
he fucked her before he fucked her,
but he said he was already like so into
it that he was like,
all right,
and then they're having a threesome with
her and the dude's getting a blow job
and he's like,
I'm looking at the back and he goes and
I realize,
I guess I'm going to have to eat this
dude's content.
And so we titled it that.
And so he did.
Yeah,
he did.
He tells his thoughts.
Episode three,
we still think it's our funniest.
What is this guy's name again?
Brian McCarthy.
He actually lives right out here.
He's Caroline McCarthy.
Is he a comic and sort of.
He hosts all these things.
He's got a show on a national lampoon
radio.
He's the funniest.
If he came in a room with a bunch of
comics,
every comic would go.
That's the funniest guy in the.
Really fucking wait a minute.
Where he would have joey is in that
room.
I'm telling you,
you can't tell me there's a guy alive.
It's funny than God is like a challenge.
So Joey nonsense as would,
uh,
would find this guy really.
Is he doing?
He's fucking weird.
There's no way to explain them.
Me,
I believe you,
but I don't believe he's funnier than
Joey Diaz.
I don't think that's possible.
He's like this fat guy that he's got a
wife and kids normal life,
but he drilling worn on the side and he
wears pink polo shirts and like white
box and any,
you know,
he's got like the secret life that he
leads and maybe you shouldn't be talking
about it on the podcast,
he told her story about smuggling weed
from Jamaica in boom boxes and getting
arrested and having to go to jail for
two and a half months in Jamaica.
You know,
when he got to America and he went to
jail.
He stayed in jail for two and a half
months rather than tell.
Call his parents to get them bailed out
because he didn't want his mom to know.
So it was just going to sit it out and
let his mom think he was in Jamaica.
Oh my gosh.
Just a fucked up.
How old was he when this happened?
Like 20 years old and Oh my God,
I just rather take two and a half months
in prison.
Jesus Christ.
So he's just wired crazy yet and yeah,
that's a dude that will fucking keep a
secret though.
That's a guy that I'd want working for
me.
Yeah.
Two and a half months.
Two and a half months in jail instead of
telling his mom,
that's a fucking soldier right there.
Yeah.
We got to soldier Ryan Mccarthy in
episode three of your podcasts and I
need to hear this now and then we have
on our show on our,
on our.
Yeah,
it's the.
It's one of the funniest stories you'll
ever hear in your real.
I swear to God he's talking about
fucking pussy and he's like,
oh,
it felt like frozen gummy bears.
That's the only thing I can describe
because I think I can get rid of all the
dick meat.
They just like,
so I'm fucking.
And he goes,
no.
If I tell you this pussy just looked
like a sloppy mess.
You should have seen the asshole,
but I couldn't get any friction in the
pussy because I guess the doctor didn't
do a good job,
so I'm pinching the pussy down and I'm
fucking fuck this guy and his asshole.
He did everything.
Oh my God,
Jesus Christ and he's not even gay.
Not at all.
What the fuck is that about?
Told a story about how he led a guy
below him one time because he was out
with this and he's.
He's not a good looking dude.
He was out with this like supermodel
chick,
like really hot,
like famous playboy model and they were
out and they were all doing coke and
partying and she goes,
I'll let you do anything you want to me
if you let this guy suck your Dick.
And he went,
well,
he goes,
what do I have to lose?
He goes,
if I,
if I like it,
then I'm gay because that solves a lot
of problems for me in life.
He's like,
so I,
I let the guy do it,
and apparently the guy that did it's
this famous writer for Vanity Fair and
he let the guy suck his dick and he
said,
as soon as he goes,
as soon as I felt the growth,
the stubble of his beard hit the base of
my cock.
He goes,
I've never gone so limp in my life.
And he goes,
I went,
I'm not gay now.
Did he fucked a chick afterwards?
He did.
Fuck the chick afterwards.
Maybe it was two coked up the fucker
that night.
But he got to afterwards.
But so the guy went,
he went limp.
Meaning that he was hard before the
stubble hit him.
He,
yeah,
he,
well,
he was,
she got them hard or something.
It was a crazy fucking story.
This dude knows how to party.
You know?
He doesn't know.
I do not want to know how to put it as
an idiot.
She sucked.
Had a guy suck his dick.
That's not a guy who knows how to party
now.
Silly.
He's A.
I would rather not.
Fuck that girl has a lot of outrageous
demands.
You know,
he's friends with,
he's friends with the dude who's a
pretty amazing dude to me,
to that own consumption junction.
Do you remember that?
Yeah.
Well I went to Arizona to do crazy
stuff,
right?
And assumption junctions all around.
I don't know if it is,
but the dude sold the website and made
millions of dollars but powerful.
I went,
he's his best friend and I went to
Arizona to Scottsdale or whatever tempe
to do,
shows that.
Right.
And he's like,
let me call my friend.
He'll show up at your show.
So the dude shows up and sits down and
starts telling me stories.
He's like,
so I'm in Panama and uh,
because you know,
there was no extradition laws there and
we're doing mountains at coke and we're
fucking these girls and I'm pissing all
over them and we're all in the shower
and there's eight girls for me and eight
girls from my friend.
And like,
these guys just live in a world that
like they make movies about and shit and
they tell me these stories and I'm like,
are they just,
are they lying to me?
That impress me because comic and then
you see his website and you go,
oh,
okay.
There's guys that are doing that.
There's Joe Frances type characters that
are like that guy.
He's notorious.
I think these guys are beyond that.
This deal now owns a website called
sugar sugar.
It depends on how much money you have.
It really does.
If you're a sociopath and you got a
billion dollars,
you can do some damage.
You can just go out there and,
and ball all the time.
I know some people that are,
uh,
that are big finance people that I'm
back in the early days of the UFC and
these guys are tons and tons of money
and Scott was ugly as fuck.
This guy used to travel all over the
country,
just banging chicks and he was always
telling me stories about being in a
Baeza and being in Russia and being here
and he's just a fucking 20th century
baller.
Sky was just roaming the country.
Roman the world rather just everywhere
party.
And it,
especially if you go to other countries
in other countries,
people just fuck.
I toured.
America is a different rap and you know
that because you,
you go to Australia like six months a
year.
I toured
for about six years extensively around
the world,
like doing China and Dubai and all these
South Africa and I saw some shady shady
shit,
like you just start finding out like a
prostitutes or $50 around the world.
And I was at a party one night in Dubai
where everyone was so fucked up.
They went all,
let's get hookers.
And when we found out they were $50,
we're like,
well let's get 10 each.
And uh,
and it was like we didn't even want to
have sex with them.
It was like,
just to like,
you know,
like it,
it started with,
well I don't know,
$50.
I just want them to come over and listen
to my jokes,
like creating your own audience.
And then everybody gets 10.
We've got 30 people.
That's a decent night in the are.
Imagine having the audience you could
fuck afterwards.
That's awesome.
Well,
that's,
that's what happened.
I'm not going to mention the names
because some of them are,
you know,
comics that work here,
but there was a whole bunch of comics
and everybody started upping the ante.
They're like,
I want to just have them come over and
fucking poor maple syrup all over them
and we're going to swim around the
fucking bathroom floor.
I want to put pringles on this is in
Dubai.
And Dubai's,
you guys worried about being arrested
because they have some really crazy laws
from the minute we got there until the
minute we left on this trip,
we were so fucked up that it never
occurred to me.
And then my next trip over I,
I got fucked up in customs and thought I
was never coming back.
What happen?
I,
uh,
I had,
didn't have the proper visa and I tried
to leave.
Uh,
I missed my flight because I was all
fucked up.
Oh,
this was the same trip on the way back.
Uh,
I tried to leave like the other two
comics got on,
got on the plane.
I missed the plane out of just being so
fucked up.
I was in an Internet cafe,
I missed the plane and then I'm like,
fuck,
the next flight's not for 24 hours to
London,
so I try to leave the airport to go to a
hotel and my,
my visa was only good for like three or
four days or whatever.
So they checked my visa,
they checked my,
my passport and they didn't match
because my agent fucked up.
Oh my agent put my,
put my middle name or something on it
somehow.
And you easily could be a spy to look at
you and spy looked to him.
God just took my passport,
walked away and I never saw my passport
again till 24 hours later.
So I'm without a passport.
The next thing I know I'm in an office
next.
I know fucking strip search I've done.
They've gone through everything in my
bag.
They've gone through my computer.
When they opened up my computer on my
heart started beating so fast that I'm
like,
because pornography is illegal in the
Middle East and they tell you don't buy.
The guys are going to try to sell it to
you in the streets.
Don't buy it,
they can be spa.
So they looked on an every folder and
your laptop,
they opened my laptop and when they
opened it I was just like,
this is it.
I'm going to be in fucking prison and be
a Middle Eastern prison for the rest of
my life because I downloaded like
topless carwash angels,
you know,
like that's like,
this is fucked.
And uh,
I had called my girlfriend at the time
because they kept making me go like
before they,
like Kinda held me in this office.
They were like,
go to this office and I'd go to this
office,
they'd be like,
go to this office.
And I kept walking down hallways and
they're like,
go down this hallway and they make me
walk down this hallway and there's a big
sign that says like nobody is allowed
past this point.
No one at all.
Like whatever in English it said it.
And I'm like,
they told me go down that hall and I'm
like,
I'm not going down that hall.
Like they're setting me up or something.
Right.
So I call her on the phone,
I've got my cell phone.
Oh,
that's crazy.
And I go,
listen,
I'm in,
I'm fucked.
I don't know what's going on,
but if you don't hear from me in two
hours,
call the US embassy and tell them I'm in
trouble.
I said something's fucked up here.
And Dubai's supposed to be like the most
progressive place in the world.
What?
But I know it's not in the world,
but I mean in the middle of the Middle
East countries,
just because they want the money.
Exactly.
Want tourism and need to be the biggest
of the desert.
Yeah.
They look the other way.
You see shit like Russian hookers
barbecuing sausages on the beach like
topless.
And you're like,
wait a minute,
there's Muslim.
Come.
Yeah,
tried it.
People been arrested.
They were making out there.
So it is just subjective.
They decide when to enforce with sex and
the city,
wasn't it?
No,
no it was real.
Real couple real.
A couple of weeks.
Weird fucking shit.
Like we had,
we had drinks,
beers on our van and uh,
I was over there another time shooting a
documentary and we had beers on the van
after we shot one night and we had a,
uh,
a female like that worked for the,
for the Emirates with us.
And the next day we find out like we're
in big trouble.
We drank around a female.
Uh,
we were swearing,
uh,
there was all kinds of shit in there.
Like they're like,
you broke every,
like sharia law possible,
don't you fuck those evidence of this?
Well,
it was kind of like I was over there
with like a guy who's really his,
his father is like the attorney for the
Emirates.
And so it was Kinda like,
you guys are okay but don't fuck up
again like you.
So do you have a mark against you now?
So if you go to Dubai now not,
I'm not,
I'm never going again.
We filmed one thing where I put on a
dish dash,
which is the Islamic will,
not Islamic,
but just the garb that they were in
Dubai and you know,
it's the white gown and the hat and they
gave me one of those when I did the UFC
and I with abby.
Yeah.
And a buddy of mine just wore them
around town.
We thought it was kind of funny and
we're just.
And we kept asking.
People were like,
well,
we're okay,
right?
We're not breaking any law.
And they're like,
no,
it's not religious.
It's just the clothing that people wear.
And then the girl that worked for the
Emirates left the Emirates and sent me
an email telling me that there were
spies watching us the whole time.
I was like,
fuck this shit.
I don't need to go back there.
Yeah.
Who was,
who's
there was telling us.
Pete Johansen was telling us that he did
gigs in Dubai and there was members of
the secret police would sit in the
audience and watch.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And it will be in the front row and
they'd be totally obvious,
I think is actually,
I don't remember if he said the front
row,
he might've said that back row,
whatever he said.
They were super obvious and they were
standing there with their arms crossed
just staring at him the whole time.
So He's trying not to cross any lines.
Try not to say anything.
The lines.
You can't cuss.
No,
no.
You can say they don't want you making
fun of Islam.
They don't remember when we had.
What's his face,
how sparks.
And he was talking about almost getting
arrested who's doing gigs with Jon
Lovitz and he made the mistake of
calling the speaking of the.
One of the sultans or one of the shakes
and he called them.
What do you call Ms Dot Moore?
Ms Dot Moore.
I think he said that.
I called them the French name for Mr.
and apparently one guy got incredibly
offended and called the religious police
and people showed up and they were going
to fuck him and put them in jail for
this.
I seriously think I could make a movie
about my weekend.
The one weekend I went there,
the risk area when there's other parts
of the country where you travel like
that where the dues,
we get used to behaving and thinking you
have a certain amount of freedom.
You know what you do here.
This is an entirely free country.
You know,
we'd still illegal.
You can't say I want to kill the
president or if you do,
they'll lock you up.
You know,
obviously it was in character when I
said that the president of the Kentucky
Fried Chicken,
you know,
you can't do certain things.
You can say it's not completely and
totally free,
but for the most part it's pretty easy
to get along here.
But if you go to other parts of the
world,
they're incredibly suppressive.
Incredible.
Especially the Middle East.
Terrifying.
You know?
That's one of the things like when
people like,
you know,
I am most certainly not for war and not
into this war,
which I think is a fucking shady war and
shady as fuck her.
We got into it.
But you have to be very careful about
the rise of Islamic power all around the
world.
The rise of [inaudible] was sharia,
sharia law.
We have to be careful of any kind of
religious zealots,
whether Christian zealots are Muslims,
Muslims,
ups or anytime.
People that think they can lock you up
and they have the right to because you
were having fun,
you know,
you were out dancing when you were out
drinking.
I have to say that's some scary shit.
I've always been,
not anti American,
but I always rebel against the
government on all things when I get over
there and this should happen.
That's when you start to really
appreciate your country that you go,
you know,
I could call the embassy and they would
take care like they fight for you at the
shore.
That's what they're supposed to do.
And they're United States citizens,
you know,
I mean,
we pay taxes.
That's what it's all about.
You know,
that's the benefits of being a part of
the team,
but it's just fucked up that we have to
think about that anywhere.
You know?
I mean,
yeah,
it's not perfect.
It's fuck corruptive shit,
you know,
super corrupt.
The fucking,
the business of government is gigantic.
You know,
there's a billion different jobs out
there that are literally don't need to
exist.
They exist to keep jobs going to keep
the business of government going and it
creates quagmires and fucking complex
little social situations.
That's very.
That's why I always say to people,
I think it's funny when people criticize
the president.
I'm like,
I'm not an Obama Fan,
but I'm not against them.
I don't believe in the whole political
system,
but I love people that criticize,
but he's the one who's in charge now.
He fucked everything up.
He's so silly.
He's like ww raw,
that whole political system and Vince
Mcmahon's,
the corporations running it all and.
But,
but people that criticize like a guy
like,
you know,
a Baldwin is healthcare Douglas.
I'm like,
dude,
you can't even fucking return your
videos to blockbuster on time.
How
it's a general lack of understanding of
what the system,
which I think most people have.
And even me,
I,
I'll,
I'll get into it,
we'll focus on for like a couple of
months and then I'll go,
what am I doing?
What am I paying attention to on paying
attention to this stupid hustle,
this fake thing that barely know what
goes on in Washington,
barely affects your day to day life.
What goes on in your neighborhood,
what goes on with your friends?
It goes on in your world,
the people that you interact with,
that's it affects your life.
If you get really too hung up and
dealing with like Washington and
politics and Democrats and Republicans
and and thinking.
You understand that system.
That's what's ridiculous.
Used to work for a senator and yeah,
it was my first job where I worked for
Ireland.
Specter,
get the fuck out of here to God that
evil cunt.
You know,
that guy was on the warrant commission.
I can tell you,
I just,
I started interning for him in college
and it was like I thought I wanted to go
into politics or something and then I
realized like I'm the.
I thought that I had the shady side that
was good for politics,
but I was like,
there's no fun involved.
It's just a fucking torture is horrible,
and they are that like everyone says
it's poor man's Hollywood specter had
like hair plugs,
facelift,
fucking horse.
You have to appear virile too.
And it was just like.
And he was the ugliest dude in the world
and he was over evil.
Fuck man.
But when he would explain his,
his single bullet theory,
if he would sit and explain it to you
after he does it,
you would believe him?
No,
I wouldn't.
You know,
I wouldn't because I've seen the bullet.
The dumbest thing about the single
bullet is the bullet itself,
but there's almost no damage went
through to people.
Shattered bone and it's barely dentist,
but I'm telling you in his presence,
he has this way of Cain.
Correct.
Incorrect.
I would not be amused or affected by
that dummy,
but it's no way that guy's an evil.
Fuck.
There's no way I would listen to him and
being charming or is he not in the
least.
It was one of those things where I was
like,
how the fuck did this guy get into
politics?
He was on her and all you have to do is
be in dude,
once you're in,
it's like being a writer on a Sitcom.
You know when you work on a Sitcom,
one of the things you find out about
working on sitcoms is there's usually a
few brilliant writers and these fucking
fakes.
These people that aren't really funny at
all,
like they would never stand up comedian
someone somehow or another got them a
job as a comedy writer and now here they
are on sitcoms and I would you deal with
them over and over and over again and
you realize all you have to do is just
get into the system.
Once you get into the system,
then you get other jobs.
I gave that speech once.
I got a deal a long time ago with a for
to do a sitcom and it was going to be
about my life and I used to live with my
sister in New York for awhile and they
thought that was funny.
You know,
to the point of view will make a show
about it.
And um,
so I met with writers or first I met
with the all the development guys and
they were like showing me the writers.
They were gonna give me and they gave me
the script of these guys and I went,
this is shit,
this is shit.
And my manager at the time was like,
shut the fuck up,
take the money.
Who's your man?
Got Up the time it was kary Hoffman
Carry Hoffman had in New York.
He owned standup New York.
Oh my God.
Stand up.
New York didn't carry,
like he would get,
like people would get sitcoms and he
would want a piece of the Sitcom because
they used to work out in this club.
Do that.
Yeah.
And that's hilarious.
He listened to the
stouffer's or listen to that guy was a
manager of a fucking calm or owned a
comedy club.
Comics would go up and then performance
club and they've got to develop.
One guy got a development deal and he
wanted like a certain percentage of this
Guy Sitcom because he used to practice
at his club.
Oh,
that's fucking stupid.
So amazing.
Of course not.
Of course.
Try really hard.
Amazing that he would even chase after
that.
So I'm sorry.
So this guy tells you to shut the fuck
up,
shut the fuck up and take the money and
I'm sitting in the meeting.
No offense.
I said,
I understand,
you know that you think these guys are
good writers and everything.
I said,
but I know this whole system,
what goes on,
guys get in and they'd get their buddy
in and he can't write and.
But then they've been there for 10 years
and you don't realize they never wrote
anything good.
They were just there and now they get to
be a show runner.
I said,
I've got millions of friends that write
funnier than this,
can I?
Can I just go out and get one of them?
And we're.
Jim and I are in that situation right
now where they're trying to do a show
with us right now and it's like we feel
like we,
we,
we could write the show.
There was a time when,
uh,
I had a development deal where there's
two guys that were,
uh,
writing for friends.
They were the creators of friends and
one of them branched out on his own and
uh,
I got this development deal and it was
for Fox and was,
it was a good amount of money.
And so they really wanted this guy to do
it because this guy has such as great
background will.
Often what happens is when there's a
team of writers,
you got one brilliant guy and the other
guys,
this fucking buddy that you bounce shit
off of,
you know.
And so the brilliant guys bouncing shit
off the other guy and then they put it
all together like maybe the other guy
types and they become a team.
So you didn't want.
Somewhere along the line the other guy
says,
you know what?
I think I'm unrecognized.
My talent from a much broader.
So this fucking idiot decides he's going
to go out on his own.
So he gets his giant development deal.
It was for um,
it was Michael Eisner's company and it
was a fucking huge development deal.
Millions and millions of dollars.
Everybody was like banking on this guy.
And so I go to meet with the guy.
They wanted me to meet with them.
I meet with them and he's wearing
bowling shoes.
And whenever I see a guy who was trying
to be wacky,
you know,
you're wearing bone bone shoes aren't
comfortable.
Those are uncomfortable as fuck.
Like why you wearing those and wearing
those to let me know that you're nutty.
You know,
I might be a multimillionaire,
but I were bowling shoes to the office.
Did you just get done bowling?
No.
You're trying to send a message.
The message is you're dressing like you
think a funny person would dress.
That tells me you're probably not
fucking funny.
So I immediately get terrified and I'm
like,
Oh,
this guy is a fucking faker.
He snuck through and there's no way.
There's no way.
How can you get this fucking gigantic
multi-multi million dollar dear if you
snuck through?
So I meet with the guy,
um,
we talk,
he has an idea.
He wants me to be a part of it.
And Bubba Bubba,
we meet and then they give me one of the
scripts.
The script that I read is fucking
terrible.
I mean,
it was just God awful.
There's nothing funny in there at all.
And I'm like,
well,
maybe this is just,
you know,
just a shit script.
Maybe he's got some other ones,
maybe there's a Spec,
maybe they had him write this,
you know,
and it wasn't a subject that he was
interested in.
So this guy comes up with the,
uh,
this is this idea for a sitcom.
Sitcom is about an immortal.
It's about a man who's immortal.
Okay.
And uh,
he,
uh,
existence like Egyptian days and all he
does is like get laid.
It's fucking devoid of comedy.
Who wants to watch a sitcom about an
immortal,
a guy who was in mortal has been a more
general sense the Egyptian days.
And all he does is try to get.
I don't understand all these hooks and
these sitcoms when you look at like the
best sitcoms that have ever existed,
that the jobs or whatever they do it.
It's,
it's so like superifilous.
It's all you need is a group of people
that hang out together and have
relationships with each other and the
interesting relationships.
If you look at like taxi and cheers and
you could move them to any other setting
and they would be funny.
You put them in an office if you didn't
matter what this guy did.
Oh,
this guy was not funny.
It doesn't matter if he wrote about
three people hanging out at a laundromat
or three people who work on the moon
just in that.
He's a fucking idiot.
He just snuck in.
That show never made it out though,
right?
Oh,
of course it didn't.
And I,
I had to tell them we had a meeting and
it was a real controversial meaning.
It was like they were upset at me
because I was like,
this guy sucks,
and they're like,
this guy does not suck.
This guy is Bubba Bubba.
He's this,
he's that.
He's done all these things and I'm like,
he's not funny.
I'm telling you,
this guy is not funny.
This is a mistake.
They'll like you don't understand.
There's more to writing and just being
funny.
There's character development and story
arts and he's a guy who really
understands that and we can bring in
more funny later,
but what he's really concerned with is
what we're concerned.
We want a really good story.
The story was deaf.
It was terrible.
It was stupid.
It didn't make any sense.
It was just like a guy who's pretending
to be a comedy writer who got a job
writing comedy.
I like if you took some fucking guy,
worked for a fence company and I was.
I'm tired of renting Francis other
organ.
I think I'm a good writer.
I've done it.
I've been doing standup for 15 years and
I.
It only,
it took me 15,
14 and about 14 and a half years to
finally realize that 95 percent of the
people in the business don't know
anything about comedy.
Like,
well,
you can't really truly understand unless
you're doing it.
I mean,
I and I've lately been putting them to
the test where I'll say,
well,
explain to me why and when you put them,
like when you put them on the hotspot
anymore or like I'll say something like,
why is that comic doing that?
Or why should he,
why do you think he's good at what he
does?
Or why isn't he,
you asking agents,
managers with development people,
talent scouts.
I always do it and I put them to it and
they'll go,
well,
you know,
he does this really interesting thing
where he's kind of like,
not really observational,
but he's kind of political buddies.
He's more on a surreal.
I'm like,
you have no fucking idea.
You have no idea.
You all are sheep and you just file.
It's not that I don't think they,
I think agents and managers are really
important,
but I think they really can't truly
understand what common is all about
unless they do it.
You know,
unless you do it,
you really never going to be an expert
on it.
You might know a lot about it,
but you're never going to really truly
understand it unless you can recreate
it.
I have an agent out of Australia,
I think you might have.
I think he might've worked with you when
you were down there already,
Lang.
Yeah.
Same name as the Howard's Guy,
but st
already is fucking like the greatest
agent that has been a great guy.
He's fucking amazing and he knows comedy
comedy a little bit and like you'll do a
bit and he'll go,
why don't you say this?
And you're like,
yeah,
that,
that would actually work better and I'll
run my sets by him before I go on TV.
And he's like,
no,
no.
Take that out.
Put that in any shit.
We're not saying that he can have some
understanding of comedy without doing
it.
You just can't really truly understand
You know?
You're never gonna understand it.
The way it comic understands it.
It's all theoretical until you put it in
practice.
It's like a guy who does caught it and
the gym is pretty sure he could farewell
in a street fight.
Yeah.
No,
but really he's not really sure it's
theoretical.
You know,
a guy who was actually fought a bunch of
times was like,
yeah,
I've been through this shit before.
I know what I'm going to do.
You know,
there's,
there's a difference and,
but there's nothing wrong with agents
and managers that don't understand it
totally because they do a great job.
You know,
I wouldn't do it and you wouldn't do it.
We're not going to sell ourselves or
we're not going to go out and get
development deals.
We can't do it anyway.
You can't negotiate for yourself.
It's impossible,
especially that end be creative like
it's important to have managers and
agents,
you know,
but they don't have to know everything.
They just have to shut the fuck up and
push in the right direction.
If you're talented,
you know what the problem is when you're
not that talented or when you're not
doing that,
well,
you haven't become successful yet.
Then they start tweaking you.
Then they start,
well,
we've got to figure out what's going on
here.
Well,
you need as a new look.
You know,
the Jamie Masada told my friend Todd
Parker that,
uh,
he had to be the generation x guy.
That's what he was saying by the younger
generation x guy.
This is your new hook.
You go on stage,
everything come out of your mouth that
gen x,
I am generation x guy.
Have you imdbs that guy now?
Lately that got the friends writer it
just to see what.
I don't even remember his name.
I don't remember his name,
but I've met a couple of those guys.
I,
I wrote something with one of those
guys,
a guy who wrote on Seinfeld.
It was fucking terrible.
He couldn't write anything funny and
wound up meeting me writing the funny
stuff and him writing it down.
It was a terrible relationship with
Carrie Hoffman.
Did that to uh,
to me that once he tried to change me,
it's like I could have no idea.
Oh,
you never see comedy duos anymore.
You and a girl and a girl and you'd do
like stiller in Mira.
Oh God.
Oh my God.
What an idiot.
Yeah.
But uh,
what does that guy still in the
business?
I think actually he's doing really well
because he's got Mike Royce and Tom hurt
to a really good writers and I think,
I think tom might be on.
I always liked the guy I'm doing.
This club is always nice to me.
Tom,
I heard that shit about him to 15
percent from.
He was kind of like a father to me.
He was that.
He was really good and he actually did
shit.
That was amazing.
Some of the shit he did was the best
stuff a manager ever did for me.
When I went to Montreal to do new faces,
he sent a tape of me to every single
person that wasn't going to Montreal and
I bombed at Montreal,
bombed and so I was fucked and then all
the people that didn't go to Montreal
saw a tape.
That was great and we're like,
he's all.
What year was this?
This is 2000 or so.
People were stopping and going to
Montreal.
By then it was Montreal kind of died
either on my.
My Year of new
faces was listening to this.
It was me.
Tony Rock,
I believe was in it.
A Dean Edwards who got Saturday night
live that year,
Demitri Martin,
Mike Birbiglia,
a Russman,
neve like everybody got something big
out of it.
And uh,
and it was like the last year though.
It was the last year because chicken was
the year before.
Yeah,
that was when I was going to bring up,
when we're talking about this,
I think we brought up chicken on the
podcast before,
didn't we?
Well,
chicken,
God rest his soul is the most amazing
phenomenon.
And this is the proof that agents and
managers have no fucking idea.
They just don't get it.
They don't know what's funny and what's
not funny.
This was,
some of them don't.
I should say this guy,
um,
he was this young kid who was just real
boyishly handsome and he had this really
wacky act like there was,
there's a screw loose in them and he had
this like really,
like completely over the top act.
It just would baffle comedian.
So we'll go.
This is not funny at all.
I don't get it too.
It was all like,
give you one.
I remember
I auditioned for snl with them.
He,
uh,
he went on stage and said so and so when
they hit a home run,
do you ever see him?
They just jog around the bases.
He's like,
they just casually jog around.
If they hit a home run,
he's like,
that was me.
If I hit a home run,
it'd be like what the fuck?
And he'd like do like flips on stage and
run around the audience and like throw
his arms in the air and be like,
I'd be flicking shit in the air out of
my life.
Would almost like if you just see a
crazy man jumping up and down in a
nightclub,
a dude's pretty crazy.
That's what he was.
Awesome.
Yeah,
he wasn't,
it wasn't that talented.
We tried really hard anyway.
He wound up getting this giant
development deal and just being a
complete total bust like they couldn't
do anything with was just not talented.
It was just awful.
And so um,
he went into this sort of dark
depression and then comics hated them.
Like he was a punchline for Comedians,
a bunch of them who just shit all over
him,
you know,
I mean,
come,
you know,
comics are,
if one guy's doing better than you and
you think he's not as good as you,
it's just fucking phantom is the.
So this kid one up killing himself in
front of a school.
We hung himself on a tree in front of
us.
Cool.
I know that.
I'm pretty sure that part of it.
I know I heard the story when he was at
Montreal though,
like there was so much hype on them
going into Montreal that uh,
like that they were bidding on him
before he even went on stage.
And I think he did as he was going on
stage,
someone said to his manager,
like,
one of the networks goes like,
we'll give you a million dollars if he
doesn't step on that stage because they
knew his price would even go up once he
went on stage and a million dollars.
His development deal was a half a
million.
Oh,
that was pretty sure that's what he got.
So they said,
we'll give you half a million for lease.
That's what the rumor was.
Go on stage because they didn't want the
bidding to even go up further.
So I don't say
lot of hype.
Yeah.
I don't think that really happened.
That doesn't really.
Nobody does that.
But there was a lot of people that were
into this kid and comics.
We'd be standing in the back of the room
watching this kid who flail around on
stage and you know,
like literally flail,
you know,
and like he was on fire and go,
what the fuck is going on?
Let's look at clips of him online.
You think that's a good question?
Michael Ruth was his name.
I think I've met him the night we did
snl.
We're,
we were auditioning at Carolina and
we're all in the green room and he comes
into the green room and all the comics
kind of know each other and then he
shows up in the green room and he's got
this energy,
you know those energy vampires that just
suck all the energy away from everyone
else.
He started bouncing around the room
going fucking crazy.
I don't know what I'm fucking doing
here.
This is like snls here and I'm fucking
like,
I'm not even a comedian.
I don't know what,
like this is crazy.
You guys like do your shit and I just
get up on stage and I'm like wacky and
fucking crazy.
And,
and everyone was just kind of,
you know,
comics were all looking at each other
like did you.
It was almost like he was psyching us
out too because we're all trying to,
you know,
this is a big deal for us.
We're all trying to get on and uh,
he's bringing you into his head.
Yeah.
And I thought that's what he was doing
and I'm like,
you're fucking with me right now and I'm
about to punch you in the face like
that.
So you thought he was doing it on
purpose?
Yeah.
And I'm,
I'm like,
I'm not going to put someone really do
that.
I think there are guys that are,
they kind of do that railing.
Yeah.
How would that work though?
That's a weird strategy to go out and do
anything.
I've found some videos if you want to
listen to one.
Yeah,
no one.
I don't like comics that go.
Yeah,
that's him,
man.
You go to the room.
Does it say anything about him?
How He's dead.
He didn't say how he killed himself.
No,
you guys got a lot of white suburban
gangster kids here.
I ain't got a voice.
You guys got little white suburb against
your kids here.
Not a gangster kids.
Seventeen year old Caucasian boys that
looked like me.
Fuck you there.
A black girl walking around the mall
here.
They got the pants hanging off their
ass.
Got The adults were going.
Oh Shit.
He pulled his pants down.
It looked like a thong he had on
dangerous,
but she 45 pounds of gold.
Gold chain.
Three gold to go in the whole fucking
time.
His name's Bradley.
Cue The plane that rap music loud as
shit.
Driving his mom minivan.
No thank you.
To want them to dance clubs.
Doing all those boody dances.
You know.
Fuck you,
dude.
You can't do it.
He pulled his pants down again.
His name is Michael Roof.
R O f.
So anyway,
that's enough of that.
Anyway,
that's not terrible.
I mean that's.
Yeah,
I mean it's not the worst comment I've
ever heard.
Funny,
when he was going down his pants the
first time he had taken his underwear
and I gave himself a Wedgie so it looked
like he had a thong on.
It was like a little touch,
a little extra touch.
It was nice
jazzed up the bit.
I like the Tagline,
the new crack tagline you added,
you know,
whatever man.
Nothing wrong with that.
I mean,
I mean it's not my style so I'm not
into,
was in closing down really well.
He,
um,
you know,
he,
he had that big development deal and
then nothing happened for it.
And then,
um,
I remember like,
so many people are so fucking happy when
nothing happened to it,
you know,
and that's when it got really ugly for
him.
Like comics were happy that he was
failing,
you know,
and then we'll just,
there was like a lot of negative energy
towards it,
but they used him as an example.
They said like,
he killed the development.
Yes he did.
He did kill it.
They gave him a ton of money and that
was it really killed.
It was their lack of real talent and
ability to recognize talent,
you know,
these,
these comics or these agents and
managers,
they're really just taking guesses and
that's what killed that were killed.
It was all these big people that spend a
lot of money and the people that were
the head of studios that people that,
you know,
they had a budget and then they're like,
why did we spend half a million dollars
on this fucking thing?
Like,
what is this?
There's a lot of that going on,
man.
You know,
like this the friends guy,
if they sat that guy down.
So just write us a couple of scripture
real quick.
Now let's look at your scripts.
Let's look at your scripts.
They read their scripts and then didn't
read anything from this guy before he
got this deal.
I know they didn't.
I know the whole story behind it.
Everybody was so high on them.
They just want to.
We're willing to throw this guy money.
I've looked at a bunch of scripts lately
and I'm like,
death,
right?
I can't do it.
I've,
I've read a couple of them and I saw and
I looked down to that and I go,
no,
I'm not even going in.
I can't go in.
I can't do this,
you know?
Yeah.
It would be nice to do a sitcom again.
I love doing news radio.
It was a lot of fun.
But good luck trying to find another one
of those.
By the way,
Dave [inaudible] was going to do the
podcast.
Don't touch with Dave Pollino very
excited.
Um,
but you know,
it's like getting a hold of one of those
sitcoms as like a fucking one of the
million and it's.
So if you don't do that,
what are you dealing with?
Well,
you're dealing with a bunch of producers
that don't really know how to do comedy.
You're dealing with a bunch of writers.
Most of them are not going to be
talented because if they were talented
they'd be working for modern family or
some of those big shows and there's not
that many really good ones that are out
there free,
you know?
So it's like your odds of finding a good
one or like one in 10,
you know,
maybe maybe one in 20.
Yeah.
I uh,
Paul prevents and I started writing a
movie together on this idea that I had
and I met Paul and Edinburgh.
I was doing the Edinburgh festival and I
kind of did the thing is a bit.
And he's like,
what?
I said,
Oh yeah,
I've tried to write a movie about that.
And he's like,
Hey,
you should write that fucking
movie.
This is the bit that you said is the
same as my bed.
The one that I talked about on the show,
very similar as A.
I had a bit that I used to do.
I did it back in the nineties.
I just talked about it on the show the
other day because we were,
we were both on the green room show
together and there was um,
we were talking about like being booed
off stage and like when people want you
to change the subject,
you're talking about like how people get
upset at you.
And I said that I used to do this joke
about cloning Jesus because there was a
thing called a second coming project.
And the second project was.
That's funny that that's what we named
the script was the second coming because
it's all about the guy jerking off is
the opening scene.
Really?
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
there was a real thing.
It was in the news about this many,
many years ago.
Anyway,
the idea was they were going to take dna
from the shroud of Turin and they were
going to recreate Jesus.
They were going to clone Jesus.
But I,
one of my job was like,
and this is a real thing,
like they really think,
I'm not sure it might've been a parody,
you know,
there's a lot of those.
The sneak through.
By the way,
Rachel maddow got busted on a parody the
other day.
She was a reading a parody.
This Christian,
it's a fake website.
And she was reading it as if it was news
that Palin's supporters really believe
that,
you know,
we have to inject Christianity into
North Africa.
And it's really funny.
And some of my bid was,
you know,
like Dolly the sheep,
when they cloned Dolly the sheep,
that Shit didn't come out perfect.
Like cloning is not an exact science.
Like what if they,
what do they do with the first Jesus if
the clone,
when it comes out retarded,
do you kill them and start from scratch
or do you just,
you know.
And so this whole bit about it.
And when I did it at the comedy store,
someone was yelling out fat white woman
with blonde hair and fat blond fingers,
just that,
you know,
I'm a Christian next subject.
Like she was so firm and her wonky
beliefs that she wanted a styling.
Just theoretical idea.
I mean it's not a real Jesus we're
talking about this is a.
and it's a real legit question.
If they really do clone Jesus,
that's a God legit question.
Like what if they found Jesus's bones
and there was some DNA inside of it and
they could extract it.
They knew for sure it was de Jesus.
They knew it was his DNA.
Well,
that's a real legit question.
What if he does come back retarded
because he could come back all fucked
up.
There could be all sorts of.
He could be autistic and psychopath
could be black as fuck with you.
What if he was my,
I think it was black.
Yeah.
Because you can't start off white and
then go put there.
Well,
there's a lot of evidence that Jesus
wasn't even real.
It was a lot of evidence that there was
no Jesus started mythologized and that
this same mythology repeats itself over
and over and over again.
So Jesus,
even as a historical figures in
question,
you know,
there's like,
volumes of,
of pages written about certain Caesar's
and certain,
you know,
rulers of,
uh,
of,
of Greece and Rome.
And so the,
the stuff that's on Jesus's,
so it's really hard to tell whether it's
real well and also all those biblical
fucking,
you know,
like everything from all the matthew,
mark,
Luke and John.
There was like,
there was the bulk of q two,
you know,
but that there's a,
there was a fifth book of the Gospels.
Apparently that was luke based.
His book on,
I'm not completely accurate and all this
stuff,
but if you start reading about it,
you'll find out that like all four of
them didn't live at the same time,
so some of them base their account
on the other ones because they'll say
it's like identical of the other one.
So it's like they just heard a story.
Yeah,
and just rewrote it,
which could have happened from the
beginning and then there was also like
the council of nicea where these guys
went in and decided the bishops all
went,
okay,
well we've got all these books.
We're going to throw out these ones.
We don't like these.
We're going to keep the.
They just rewrote history the way they
wanted it.
So I mean it's like shit like that on
there for you.
If you find out about the New Testament,
that's where things get really weird
because constantine and a bunch of
bishops create that New Testament.
That's the know what you're talking
about.
Something that was way after Jesus's
death.
You know,
if Jesus was a real figure,
the whole thing is fucking squirrely.
You know,
the historical account just mean not
even saying the religious accompany
historical accounts various quarterly.
I don't know about it.
Like Dolly being retarded.
I've often wondered like,
you know,
when like a dog bite someone,
everybody's like,
oh,
he's a bad dog or whatever.
I'm like,
you see people all the time,
like people with down syndrome.
Are there like down syndrome dogs?
Yes.
I'm going through minds where your
fucking dogs retire.
Yeah.
It's totally retarded dogs.
Just really,
really overbred you know,
you have uh,
uh,
one of those little dogs.
What's it called again?
A Pekinese.
Yeah,
those dogs,
man.
Guess what?
That came from a wolf.
Yeah.
There's no way you get a good example if
that is what you get from a wolf.
I think my dog might be part wolf.
Really?
Yeah.
It's,
she's,
she's a,
she's an ozzy cattle dog and cheese.
I grew up with Jack Russell terriers.
You ever see those little short locking
the assholes?
And they,
uh,
the really aggressive because they used
to kill rats.
Fucking solo aggressed send them after
we lived out in the woods and these
things would do one of them.
One of them went down a A.
I couldn't find him.
One night I find them down a sewer under
the road and there's A.
I'm looking down the sewer grate.
I see them and there's a pipe way down
underneath it runs out to a creek and
I'm like,
fuck.
He ran up the pipe and he's under the
sewer.
There's no way for me to get him.
I looked down,
he's got a raccoon cornered.
Oh my God.
And I'm like,
fuck,
he's dead.
He's dead,
this raccoon and she's going to an all
and I'm just going,
come on,
like try to coach them out the.
And I'm screaming,
screaming,
and all of a sudden I hear and it goes
and I'm like,
fuck,
my dog's dead.
My Dog's dead.
And I'm shining a flashlight and I don't
see anything.
Next thing I know my Jack Russell drags
the raccoon out of the pipe on Jack
Russell killed a raccoon cut to about a
year ago.
I,
my dog's leash lists all the time.
People you can call me an asshole,
but I don't believe in putting a dog on
a leash.
And my dogs well behaved and she's
amazing.
I saw the dogs won't be hey,
as long as you really know the dog as
well behaved.
Just when people walk around with like
pitbulls without just.
Yeah,
my dogs.
Amazing.
And so the way I used to do that,
like a retard when I,
when I,
when I get close to home,
I'll go,
go,
go home and she'll run like 200 meters
up the road.
So I one I'd see this cat and she
chased,
she never would hurt a cat but you'll
play with them.
So I go,
go,
go.
There's a cat.
You told him to chase the kid and she
just plays with the cat.
And uh,
so she goes running up the road
and all of a sudden I hear her go ma and
I'm like,
oh fuck,
she's,
you know,
she's now fighting with a cat and she's
never fought before.
And I come around the corner.
It's not a cat,
it's a fucking raccoon.
And I'm like,
fuck.
And the cat takes or the raccoon takes
off.
So you totally chase after a raccoon
thinking it was a cat.
And how did you mistake the,
it was so far away.
It was like 200 yards away.
So I wake up the next day and they see
my dog sitting there and the eyes are
crusted shut.
And I'm like,
what the fuck?
So I take her to the vets and uh,
the record scratch both their corneas.
Yeah.
Oh God.
And he said,
the vet said these things will rip your
dog apart.
They,
they will fucking junkie texting and
tweeting while he's trying to have some
convoluted conversation.
They said they'll rip your dog apart.
And I said,
well,
what about the rabies?
And he said that rabies aren't bad in
California,
but uh,
it's not bad.
But the rackets fucking fucking scary
man recommended.
There was when I lived in new Rochelle,
New York,
I had a big one in my neighborhood.
He used to fuck up trash cans.
He was gigantic.
I mean,
it was like a dog.
I couldn't believe how big he was.
And I,
I got a blow gun just so I can try to
kill him.
And I was terrified.
I opened the door,
it was a small,
I had a small little yard and I would
open the door and he would literally be
fucking 10 feet from me.
I panic and slam the door.
I'm like,
get out of here,
bitch.
My,
my old dog Cabo at one site level,
Islam out the backyard and just to go to
the bathroom and I'd let them out and
instead of going around like,
oh,
what's going on?
So I go outside and it's two skunks,
like corner did my little backyard and
the dogs about to attack them.
And I'm just thinking I don't want to
get sprayed and want the dog to get
sprayed.
Takes forever to clean.
My dog got sprayed when I was a little
kid.
It's the worst.
It takes forever.
You use tomato juice.
Apparently there's an enzyme and
tomatoes that helps break it down,
but not much tomato and it doesn't work.
You got to keep doing it over and over
and over again.
The stuck for weeks.
Have you ever heard the Billy Burger bit
about raccoons?
Was the raccoon and the little hand
stealing the cat.
The youtube video.
It's the hardest I've ever laughed at a
joke in my life.
I don't think I met a Mustang.
I saw him at the Improv one night.
It was recently,
so it's probably like in his new set,
but it's billy shelly,
you know,
angry billy gets.
He's still angry watching this youtube
video where a raccoon keeps stealing
like cat food,
like it comes over and keep stealing the
food from the cat or from the dog or
something and he keeps going.
This little fucking raccoon hands and
tears were coming out of my eyes.
I was laughing.
I've never laughed that hard at a comic
store.
Check it out because he's so angry about
the little hands and he's like,
I'm the fucking little mask on this
room.
It's pretty crazy that all.
And all dogs came from wolves.
Yeah.
You know when they figured out that
genetic lineage of dogs,
they expected to be a bunch of wild
candidates in there.
A bunch of different kinds of canines.
Nope.
Wolves.
All.
Originally it was a wolf or what about a
Dingo?
It's a different kind of dog and
welcoming.
It's a candidate.
A wild.
Okay.
I know if there's specific ones,
that Dingo doesn't come from a wolf,
does it?
I don't know.
That's a good question.
It's an Australian thing.
Yeah.
The dingoes eat babies Australia.
My dog looks like a Dingo.
Do Kangaroos kill people?
There was a recycling of discussion one
time I got out of a car and uh,
I thought it was a fucking,
like,
we're driving through this neighborhood.
I don't know why we're in this
neighborhood.
Simple yes or no hair.
I don't know,
but I've heard stories that yes,
because when we went to the zoo in
Australia,
they told us the big ones,
the big.
There's big Kangaroos.
I forget which kinds of the big ones.
What are the red ones?
The gray ones.
The big ones.
Kill people.
And they have a bunch of times.
They said you have to be very careful if
you approach them in the wild.
This thing I read the other day,
it said like a hundred people die a year
from it.
And then this other website,
it's like a,
there's been a few known attacks in the
history of,
you know,
yeah.
There was one woman recently,
her dogs were killed.
The most recent attack that I could find
online.
And this kangaroo drowned her dogs.
That's pretty high.
Fuck gangster IRA's grout.
Drown your dog.
I saw the biggest fucking kangaroo and I
thought it was a statue in these
people's yard.
And I was like,
fuck,
who has this giant kangaroo statue?
I mean like 10 foot tall white.
Looked like it was.
No,
once they get to be like seven feet
tall,
as tall as your ceiling and come off,
I swear to God.
And I got out of the car.
So this is like a 10 foot ceiling.
How many feet?
Ten feet.
I was,
uh,
two other comics and I see this thing
over by these garbage cans.
I'm like,
Holy Shit.
Look at this fucking thing.
And I start walking towards it and this
comic named Tommy Johnson goes,
get out,
fuck back in the car,
make fucking get in the fucking car.
And I'm like,
what?
And I'm walking towards it.
And all of a sudden I see it move and
now he's like,
Hey,
don't fucking dishes made it.
I'll fucking gun.
Wow.
That's what they claim.
I think it's like an urban myth that
they just fucking rip your stomach.
Oh No,
no.
It's not an urban myth.
People definitely have been attacked in
that manner.
They just got punched in the red.
The red kangaroo is the big one.
I'm just trying to find out how that
would fucking freak me out if I saw a
kangaroo that big.
Yeah,
no shit.
I don't think they're that big though.
I think you were afraid they were that
big.
I love to try to like ride around in
your ceiling.
I didn't think it was 10.
I thought it was about seven.
I'd say seven,
seven feet tall.
This fucking thing.
Yeah,
that's what they told us when we went to
the zoo and in Australia it was fucking.
Oh,
okay.
Here we go.
They can go to eight feet tall and
weighed 200 pounds.
Wow.
Holy Shit.
Why ever seen those videos?
Week leaking feet.
Fucking tall.
Terrified.
That's insane.
I've seen herds of them down and Donna's
is amazing.
You ever seen those videos of the
kangaroos fighting on like the golf
courses in Australia?
Yeah.
That's where you see them on the golf
course.
It's not the red kangaroo with a gray
kangaroos.
A big one,
right?
Isn't that the Big One?
I don't know if you ever see guys fight
them.
The eastern gray,
the boxing love Jesus Christ did know
the red kangaroo does grow to nine feet.
Fucking tall.
Holy Shit,
dude.
It doesn't weigh as much as the gray,
but the red grows to nine fucking food.
It the scariest thing because I got.
I got,
I got from here to the curtain.
I was 10 feet away from it.
Fuck that.
And I was walking to it because I swear
to God it looked like a statue and all
of a sudden moved to town and I went,
oh my God,
that's fucking alive and Holy Shit.
That is so big yet.
And this comic was just start yelling
out the gas fuck in the car.
Whoa man.
Wow.
Yeah.
That's scary thing.
And they apparently,
while people are content to them,
I'm sure that's probably why people hate
them.
They think they're rodents.
Will they kind of are?
Yeah.
I mean they,
they're kind of girls.
I think they're kind of cooldowns girls
must feel so fortunate that are not
rats.
All they needed was just a fluffy tail
and groovy and no plague will just eat
nuts.
You don't have to eat garbage.
Okay,
cool.
Cool.
Have you seen the viral video yet?
Or the rat that goes up the guy's face?
What?
Oh yes.
On the subway.
You get everybody to tell me about New
York City.
Rents are fucking terrifying.
I remember when I lived in New York,
I think I've told this story,
but I'll tell it again for this.
I was at a gas station once and I went
to use up sofa a payphone.
This is how old this story is.
You know,
there was no,
I didn't have a cell phone,
so I stepped away from my car.
Well,
my car is pumping gas and I go to the
payphone and I'm on the payphone and
while I'm on the payphone I'm watching
rats,
big ones like cats jumped in the wheel
housing of my car,
climb on the tires,
climbed down,
and I am your car.
Yes,
I'm fucking 15 feet away.
I stepped over to use the payphone and
as I'm standing there on the phone,
I've watched these rats and they keep
going down this opening in the manhole.
There must have been thousands of them
down there the way they were coming up
so quickly and in,
in,
in such rapid succession.
One after the other,
one after the other,
and then down one after the other one.
I'm like,
there's just a train of them down there.
And I went and reported my car stolen.
So scary dude.
More rats than people in the air.
Like for.
I think it's for rats for every person.
Oh my God.
I was walking down macdougal street one
time hump from the seller one night and
I'm just walking through it and then you
know,
people with their garbage out in the
street for the garbage men to pick them
up.
I'm going between garbage and a building
and all of a sudden a rat just will runs
out from the garbage and uses.
My foot is like a hurdle.
Little feet touched my foot and it was
the most I've ever been like a woman in
my life.
I started like jumping up and down like
screaming because it's like,
it's like that fucking like adrenaline
rush goes and you can't fight.
You're just like,
ah,
what the fuck.
It was as big as you were.
Such pussies were such pussies compared
to animals were so soft and mushy and
fleshy.
I think it's the the filth though of the
rats.
That's just the film.
They're furious.
They're fucking army as much as the
filth of those.
They you feel like they carry hepatitis
and aids and the black plague isn't that
connected to rants is not all my rent's
not a bunch of plagues had been about
ransom.
They're horrible carriers of diseases.
Who is it?
Jim Norton and uh,
I think as Jim Norton and rich Vos used
to go to this one park in New York and
sit there and watch
the rats and they said you'd see like
thousands of these racks.
There's so many of them.
Manhattan,
Manhattan is so crazy with rats.
I was at a pool hall,
wants a New Jersey and this is the
scariest read I ever saw was with my
friend John.
We went,
we were doing a Gig and we stopped home
from the Gig to play some pool.
We stopped this pool,
get out of the car and as I'm walking
towards the door,
there's a dumpster like outside.
And as I passed by the dumpster,
there's the biggest rat I've ever seen
in my life.
I mean it is like a raccoon.
It was gigantic.
No bullshit.
I'm not bullshitting.
It was two and a half,
maybe three feet long in the body.
It was enormous and it had these shoes,
huge fucking nasty yellow teeth.
And I don't know if it was sick or
dying.
I mean,
it might have been old age because it
was so big,
it might've been the end of the line for
this fucking thing,
but it was up on its back legs and was
going like this to me and I was
thinking,
do I kick this thing?
Do I get a rock?
What the fuck?
I was just such a little girly man.
I'll never forget that noise.
When you got to think with all the
poison.
They lay down,
like you'll see the signs of the subway
saying,
you know,
careful,
there's like poison everywhere.
Ran with.
They've got to be adapting and mutating
and we're making some fucking scary rat
just chorus,
right?
Yeah.
I mean that's what happens with
bacteria,
right?
That's where we're at.
Murcia know that staph infection that
people get this antibiotic resistant.
That's what it is from fucking.
Is that like the superbug?
Yeah.
Well the mercer has the super staff.
It said Mike,
I don't know what it actually stands
for,
but it's something resistant staff.
So it's a antibiotic resistance.
So when people get it,
it's like really,
really dangerous and it's really just
created by human beings,
by,
you know,
I was fighting off different versions
until the only ones who survive are
super fucking strong.
It's why it just read the other day that
80 percent of all the antibiotics in
America are given to animals like they
pump them full of antibiotics and the
same bacteria that we've used
antibiotics to fight off.
So do animals.
So all the antibiotics they're taking is
causing the bacteria to butyrate,
which is making us immune to these
antibiotics to live.
Is that true?
Because,
um,
I was on a,
on a,
I did a thing about,
um,
uh,
talked about food inc and I got
contacted and this is one of the coolest
fucking things about this podcast.
I got contacted by a bunch of scientists
fuck food scientists,
you know,
people who are,
um,
you know,
involved in the farms and one guy who
worked for a poultry company.
And uh,
he was,
uh,
talking to me about it.
Let me find it here.
That shows the difference between your
listeners in ours.
You have all these intelligent people
that are really interested.
We get guys who were like,
you guys are fucked guns.
Well I get those to watch corn too.
By the way.
Have you ever get the chance to watch
the documentary that that's where they
even go into more detail about having
like having holes on the side of the
cows.
So creepy and Food Inc.
There's a whole.
Well,
well iT's according to this guy.
First of all when he wanted it and his
name is Jacob Kim.
So thank you jacob.
At one of the things that he explained
to me is that chickens are not on
steroids and then what it is is just
genetic selection and they've naturally
selected birds with bigger and bigger
breasts to the point where they're
freaks.
So they wouldn't have survive if they
were a real animal,
but you know,
because we grow them just for their
tits.
So.
And he also said that What they're
supposed to do is they're supposed to
cycle the antibiotics.
So when a bird is sick,
so like they have a cycle,
like there's 49 days,
he says to grow a bird.
So in business terms,
the pharmacy's profits go down as the
flock stays longer than that.
So in the instance that a 30 day old
flock get sick while they're supposed to
wait 21 days before they killed them.
So when they,
when they get sick,
they're going to lose like 10 or 11 days
of profit.
So if they do something like that and
lose these days a prophet,
you know,
it's like a problem with them.
So some unscrupulous companies don't
follow that.
And then they send out the bird,
you know,
like 15 days later in the birds still
pumped up with antibiotics and has a
process to your system.
You're saying,
I can't believe you know,
I fucking data one thing that I didn't
do right code for.
shut it off your fucking cops.
My new phone number.
you fuckheads for giving out at all to
one 800 faggots.
Oops.
I said that shit.
A retiree.
Stay away From that word.
Yeah,
he retired it.
It's been a,
it's been feeding.
It's been growing in him lately.
I find it a funny word.
Yeah,
I,
I don't.
I mean,
I'm never going to retire a word,
kind of like.
Yeah,
I always said like when they tried to
retire the n word,
I go,
what are they going to do?
Put it on a banner and raise it into the
rafters at like the apollo theater,
right number that's retired United
States,
something that were,
some gay guy gets mad at me and I'll
just flirt with them alone.
So he goes to site,
don't be mad.
I don't get right now where I say it,
I go,
uh,
you know,
like the,
the reason that like gay men are more
sexually promiscuous than men and women
is the [inaudible] because they've got
time and energy from not fighting all
the time because a gay fight,
you know,
it's Just like,
hey,
those shoes don't match your belt.
And he's liKe,
really?
Let's fuck,
you know,
like that's gay guys beat the shit out.
And that's the other thing.
Gay guys can beat the shit out of each
other and the cops show up.
Like what happened?
He punched me,
will hit them back.
Faggot.
That'S funny.
Um,
so anyway,
back to this guy.
So the guy was explaining to me,
so no steroids for chickens,
that's not true.
But there it is true for cows.
So cows are jacked,
cows are totally jacked up on hormones,
no hormones at all or no hormones,
no steroids on chickens because I,
I eat,
I eat all grass fed stuff.
Yeah.
I order all my meat from us.
Wellness meats.
Yeah.
Uh,
no,
no.
It's good.
Grass fed beef tastes really good.
Fucking had a strip last night.
And pork chops,
grass fed pork chops,
you know,
I agree.
We need pop shields by the way because
pork chops makes a big terrible noise in
people's ears.
I ordered those.
I'm soon.
But I uh,
yeah.
I eat
a paleo diet.
Do you know that?
Yeah.
So I eat that diet and,
and um,
in all the grass fed shit and my chicken
breasts that I get are grass fed and
they're fucking massive.
And I'm like,
this is weird.
I heard the whole thing was when you buy
organic and grass,
that you're Just not getting the fuck
they're bigger chemicals on the grass.
How is that possible?
I don't know what's going on in that
grass.
Oh,
hey.
So what did you think about that movie
to avoid?
I saw it last night.
I shut it off after the car accident
when the fucking the parents were killed
in a car accident.
I'm like,
first of all,
you've just,
you showed me a girl who's a prostitute
and a stripper.
Okay.
And then you showed her happy family.
Fuck you.
That's more science fiction in the dmt
shit because that's just shitty writing
to me.
You're showing me this.
This girl loves her brother.
And how much do you love me?
I love you so much.
You're just jerking with my emotions,
man.
This isn't good story writing.
This is nonsense.
What I liked about the movie was the
first person perspective.
It was like I was in a video game that
was cool.
King of the.
I even remember like you could actually
see it where the character blinks.
They would have it like every,
like randomly every five,
10 seconds.
And then when he goes into the dmt trip,
did you think that was a pretty
realistic?
No,
I thought it was interesting.
Yeah.
But it wasn't realistic.
First of all,
you couldn't explain what the dmt trip
looks to a person.
You couldn't recreate it with like cgi.
Right.
Because what it is isn't possible.
What your will.
You'll see.
It doesn't make any sense what I'm
saying.
But when you have a dmt trip,
you're not seeing anything that can be
recreated.
It's impossible to recreate.
It's like when I'm watching there was
just some swirly cool shit and like
really interesting.
But when you see it,
when you see a dmt trip,
it's just,
first of all,
it's a million things at the same time
it's a bunch of different things.
It's no matter how you,
depending how you look at it,
it's a different
thing.
I really liked how there was so much
detail too because I've noticed this on
past hallucinate trips before,
like,
like little things like after he was
tripping,
like he shut this door and the door kind
of have like a red pulse when he showed
it and stuff like that.
Now,
what did you think about the big,
even at the very beginning where you
were hypnotized in a seizure where it's
just flashing all those logos crazy like
that happens throughout the movie and
some points you're just like,
all right,
they're brainwashing me right now.
This is,
this is from the government or google.
Hey dom,
that kind of shit though.
I'm starting to wonder about that with
every.
I'm such a,
I'm not a conspiracy theorist,
but I am paranoid.
So really I'm completely paranoid and a
or I can get there and I've got to like
a close the neuropathways,
you know,
and just fucking try to bring myself
back from it because I can go totally
into that where I'll start thinking like
anything like a fucking sitcom,
you know,
like,
well,
you had a real freakout recently.
We talked about this on the green room,
uh,
where you,
you,
uh,
you got super paranoid from weed.
Yeah.
And I've had,
it happened.
It was the second time it happened.
The first time I had a pot cookie in
Australia.
The second time I just smoked.
But you said something really
interesting to me and he said,
I can't smoke pot.
I said,
yes you can.
He said,
I have to go to therapy first.
Yeah,
like what do you have to go therapy
about breathing exercises?
I don't fucking know,
but it just put me into panic attacks
and.
Well,
I thought,
I thought it was just the wheat.
The first time it happened.
It didn't happen.
We smoked weed before.
Didn't we smoke weed in Florida?
You know,
it's another funny story.
Know what's a funny story.
One time I was at a medicinal marijuana
benefit that you were like playing.
You were like doing a show at the comedy
store for him.
Calico,
brian kaylin and I came over and uh,
some girl was with you like,
like that was in charge of it or
something.
and she goes,
she had these muffins and I had no idea
that I didn't know that you were a big
pothead.
I didn't know that.
What it was.
And I was starving and she goes,
do you want a muffin?
And unlike,
yeah,
have a muffin.
So I ate the muffin and I'm like,
these are really good,
and she's like,
yes.
And then I count goes,
what's a show?
And you go,
oh,
it's a benefit for medicinal marijuana.
And I go,
it clicked.
I went,
did I just fucking eat a pot muffin?
And she says,
yeah.
And I went like this,
I can't go.
I gotta go,
I gotta get home right now.
And I drove home as fast as I could
because I knew it would take 20 minutes
for it to kick in and I just didn't want
to be out with it going on and just be.
And I was like,
fuck,
I got it.
Because I had done.
I'd eaten pot cookies before and I was
like,
I gotta get the fuck what happened?
So I drove home as fast as I could.
I get home and it kicks in and I just
didn't have the fucking greatest
experience all alone.
And I'm having like a wonderful night
and I called a girl.
I know,
can you go to 7:11
for me?
I need this,
this,
and I just was laughing and she's like,
you use your high and like,
yeah,
yeah.
But the first time I did it was in
Australia and I had such a great time.
I had to do a show three nights in a row
by the third night.
The same exact audience.
Oh my god.
Every night.
That's ridiculous.
So by the third show I'm out of shit,
you know,
I've,
I'm down to my worst stuff and I'm like.
So right before I went onstage,
I hit a pot cooking thinking be,
and I did like an hour and 45 minutes
and they're like,
it was fucking brilliant.
And unlike,
what did I talk about?
They're like,
you've talked about the mach three razor
for an hour.
And I'm like,
really?
And they're like,
we don't even have it here.
That's ready to record yourself.
I would have been
great.
I've had a two freakouts were one went
to the hospital and it wasn't related
top related.
Uh,
and once we're in the ambulance came to
my house and I,
I,
but now I don't get that anymore.
I don't get that anxiety or anything
like that unless I eat it and then when
I eat it,
it's not good.
Well,
also,
I mean it depends on what's going on in
your life at the time.
you think I should be getting paranoid.
I should be dead right now because I
smoke pot every day.
My life's crazy.
You know?
Life's crazy.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
just all the shit lately,
if that's what you're saying.
No,
I don't think you're crazy,
man.
I think your life is saying her now than
it was just a couple of years ago.
Do you remember you.
Well,
you know,
I don't wanna get into personal details,
but you know what I'm talking about.
Um,
the,
the problem is all right and here's the
number
one problem with eating it is it nobody
knows what the fuck it does to you.
You know,
nobody tells you they just sell these
things at the pot stores.
What was that?
A pot brownie.
Oh,
I'll try eating it.
Not knowing that it's way more powerful.
Way more powerful and it lasts forever.
I hate a pot brownie wants and I swear
to god it lasted 12 hours,
so this first one lasted about 12
fucking and they told me it was funny.
I was having a great time.
I was in adelaide,
Australia.
I'd been drinking all day and then I ate
half a cookie and they said just eat
half.
Nothing happened.
I go,
I'm going to have the other half.
And they were like,
all right.
I did the other half having a great time
and all of a sudden I turned around.
I got up to go to the kitchen.
I turned around and looked at theSe
girls and I go make it stop.
WhAtever we have to do to stop this.
Let's stop your trip.
Yeah.
I was like,
can we,
is there any way to like abort right
now?
And they're like,
all right,
calm down.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
We need to fucking stop this.
and they're like,
why are you being such a bitch?
I don't know.
But.
But what started happening,
it was around a bunch of girls,
man,
let's pull it together.
Hey,
remember when excerpt out of fear
factor,
I had to sit with all those girl interns
in their car and put it together though
he didn't yell at anybody to make it
stop.
I thought my eyeballs were trapped and
when he first came here from Ohio,
he had nothing.
He had no resistance.
He was used to this Ohio.
We'd,
which you might as well been mixed
mexican brick weed,
might've well been smoking talcum
powder.
It's nonsense.
That's a terrible example.
Gold bond and I gave him a lollipop.
These,
these fucking beyond bomb.
Before beyond bomb went to jail.
They were operating a multimillion
dollar operation at oakland and the dea
rated them during the bush
administration and we had to.
We had one on the way there and then
half hour later you're like,
you feel anything?
I'm like,
no,
not relating.
And so we took another one because we.
I think you were new to the lollipops to
at the time we didn't really know the
length of how long the wait may panic
attack right now.
sitting in where he drops me and goes,
oh,
hang out here in this trailer.
It was like the trailer with all the
managers and directors and producers and
stuff like that and I'm just thinking
about not knowing anybody and it hits me
were all super friendly but they're
totally cool,
but I mean my heart started pounding.
I started freaking out.
I go and sit on the curb and then in
between breaks you come on and like,
how are you doing?
I'm like,
dude,
I'm so fucking stone and having a panic
attack,
and you're like,
dude,
I still have a mic on her when it's a
now everything.
Everybody in the trailer now hearS me
and he like dropped me off in these
interns car and just sat there and
talked about fucking sex and the city or
something.
I think
I told you this.
I know this,
these,
these little dudes that I used to kind
of.
It was a girl that was friends with her
little brothers and they were big
potheads in high school and we used to
hang around.
We're in college at their house and they
always.
They were up to no,
like they grow it in their backyard.
They tried everything so they were.
They were making pot cookies one night
and they make them,
they leave them out,
that kind of a wealthy family.
They have like a maid and everything.
They leave the pot cookies out because
parents are always out of town.
The maid puts them in baggies and puts
them in the.
In the cookie canister.
Dad comes,
grabs
two cookies,
cookies and eat some rushed to the
hospital thinking he's having a heart
attack.
So I say to the kid like,
they're telling me the story.
I'm like,
so did you tell them?
They're like,
fuck,
no,
that's hilarious.
So did he ever figure out that he was a.
I don't medicate it.
Like the whole family had a panic
attack.
Hey,
yeah,
you know,
I'm one kid went to jail because a,
they dose their teacher up in school.
They gave the teacher pot cookies.
I remember in high school used to always
try to sneak in a laxatives and our
teachers coffees and stuff and I look
back and I'm like,
that's fucking rude because I mean,
I remember getting dangerous too.
It's an evil I heard of.
I heard about a fraternity wanting all
these dumb fraternity price.
I forget where it was his college at,
like George Mason when I was doing a
show there.
They go,
oh yeah,
we got this fraternity that at the end
of hell week they,
uh,
they feed them spaghetti.
They give them this big spaghetti dinner
that the lake little sisters make for
them and then they feed them like
chocolate pudding,
but it's full of x slacks and then they
make them climb a tree and they've got
to spend the night in a tree.
Like the top guy gets to go to the top
of the tree and all the way down.
So like if you're an asshole,
you're down at the bottom shitty.
Just all shitty things are so
disgusting.
They're juSt preparing you for just to
be fucked with and to be in some country
group where you get to fuck with new
people.
Just taking advantage of the people that
have the least amount of power and the
people that want the most from you.
The other good thing about fraternities
was going to their parties and like
fucking those sorority girls stand up at
a fraternity wants.
I'm pretty sure I know as opposed to a.
I did a lot of college,
a lot of college gigs and like weird
spots like cafeterias and shit rec rooms
and did one in the cafeteria where I had
to stand on actual cafeteria tables.
It was like,
that was the stage.
It was a table and still on a cafeteria
table.
But um,
one,
one fraternity stunt that I heard that
was the craziest was they made this guy
drink water and he died from water.
Oh,
water.
What's that called?
Hitting a tree.
Mia.
Yeah.
pretty much are drowning yourself.
It's not nuts style,
but just turns out all your salt and
then you know,
this happens with this new starbucks
size.
Jesus christ.
I've been drinking this ice tea forever
and I'm still only like bulletins.
Hold it up to the camera.
It's for folks that don't see it at
home.
This is the new starbucks.
Thirty two ounce and this is a,
this is just an ice coffee or an iced
tea rather.
Yeah.
Here's the,
here's the old size,
here's the other side.
And it's thicker too or bigger.
It's not only tolerant,
but it's wider,
wider.
I got that hit in a marathon.
I ran a marathon.
You drank too much water.
I panicked like,
you just shouldn't change your fucking
habits,
but everybody goes,
oh,
you know,
make sure you hydrate,
make sure you're hydrated,
make sure you hydrate.
So I drank like,
fucking like 10 bottles of water before
the race.
Like,
oh wow.
And uh,
I knew I started pissing like so much
that I went,
fuck,
I'm going to piss all my salt out.
So I went up to.
I never thought about that.
Every day in my life I went up to the
coffee table and a coffee and I go,
I go to this woman.
I go,
do you have salt packets?
I need fucking salt.
I just wanted to down some salt,
just big fat black woman goes,
who puts salt in their coffee?
And I'm like,
just get me fucking salt.
And I knew it was going to fucking
happen and sure enough I hit like the 16
mile mark and I hit a wall.
I'd never hit my life because I was just
nothing left in.
Never heard of anybody doing it.
I never even thought about.
I know a woman,
um,
died in,
I think it was sacramento.
I want to Say there was a radio stuff
they did was,
she had a drink,
a lot of water.
That was like a year and a half ago,
two years.
And it was like we were on the cross
town radio station,
you know,
we were on like one of their competitors
stations and they were telling us a
story.
Like,
how fucked up it was,
you know,
that's,
that's.
I remember that shit man.
Death,
some water woman who is trying to win
like on xbox for kids.
I think some northern California
sacramento,
I thought it was,
but yeah,
it might be san jose,
but in northern California,
whatever it is,
but it's just like,
fuck man,
drinking water,
drinking water were so bitchy.
Were so fragile.
This is there a dog out there that could
die.
Because he drinks too much water.
No,
we suck.
We're such pussies.
You have it.
It's,
that's an anomaly.
That's like a.
Then you see guys that I know,
dude,
who this fucking crazy dude that I know
from New Jersey who drank bleach and
he's a lot.
He's the dumb is this guy went to penn
state and my friends all know him and
they all talked about him.
I finally got to meet him and he's just
a fucking maniac.
He sells mack trucks now.
I think that's what he does for a
living.
And uh,
they,
they knew him from this fraternity.
They're like,
this dude fell off the roof for time.
Everybody knows a guy like that.
And I'm like,
why would you keep climbing up there?
And they're like,
they put,
they would like put like signs don't let
them on the roof to still go up there
and fall off.
So they tell me he chugged bleach and
I'm like,
I get a shot of it or something.
And I go,
I don't believe it.
I don't believe until I need them one
night or I see him and I go,
hey dude,
uh,
I go,
hey dude,
I think his name is reagan or something
like that.
Is it true you,
you drank bleach?
And he's like,
yeah.
And I go,
well,
why?
and he goes,
because it said on the bottle if you
drink this you will die.
Am I dead?
no.
And that was like his whole point,
like a philosopher.
I know homeless people used to drink
rubbing alcohol when they couldn't get
real alcohol or something like that.
You remember michael dukakis?
yeah.
Michael dukakis.
When he ran for president who's running
for president and his wife,
kitty dukakis was such an alcoholic that
she'd be began drinking shaving cream
and shit like that.
Yeah,
she,
she was drinking like nutty shit and she
got rushed to the hospital.
I believe he was shaving cream or
something,
you know,
shave something nutty.
Do you work the stress factory in New
Jersey?
I have vinnie brand told me a story.
I forget the comic.
I think he was one of those like famous
prop comics,
but in his day was like a really bad
alcoholic and I'm like,
I could be wrong with who the comic is,
but a lenny shoultz lenny,
I don't think it was lenny because I
think the guys did is not that izzy,
I don't know whoever it is I think is
dead now.
But glen,
he was really old fucking vinnie's
office and drank cologne.
Like he came out and it smelled his
breath and was like,
what the,
like he was that much of an alcoholic
like chicks.
Have you ever heard of it?
Like when girlS fall asleep with a
hairdryers in their beds,
that's like an actual,
you know,
a lot of girls do that to keep warm or
something like that or a sound of it.
And they,
uh,
if you ever heard of that before,
they just full blast hairdryer and they
stay in their bed,
in their bed and it's actually a
condition that's awesome.
People are so nuts,
man.
This kitty dukakis thing,
um,
she was rubbing alcohol.
that's what she drank,
you know,
um,
I guess she was rushed to the hospital.
I mean,
I guess you can die,
but how crazy is that this guy was
running for president,
which just goes to show you how much
your world is falling apart when you're
running for president.
You know what I mean?
How much effort do you have to put into
it?
It's a reason why these guys go gray
like a year after they get into office,
you know,
the amount of stress and the,
the.
I mean he wasn't paying attention to his
wife at all.
You don't.
You think you'd know if your wife was
ready to drink rubbing alcohol.
I just,
baby.
How you feeling or thinking about
drinking some.
let's talk.
Hold on.
Listen,
I can't talk to run for president,
but don't drink alone.
I'll be back in 20 days.
Maybe I'm talking about drinking some
room clean.
Don't drink my perfume.
She was apparently she was taking
antidepressants or something too.
She had been taking an antidepressant,
prescribed antidepressants back in the
eighties.
You know,
where they want to make a ground up
leeches.
What did they,
would they serve you in 1989 for
antidepressants?
Cocaine killed the whole.
What can I enter the questions they
have?
They didn't have the good shit.
Just drink a coke.
Thorazine?
No,
that was for.
Listen,
that list gets a friend or something.
I dunno.
prozac,
right?
Wasn't prozac and whether the early
ones.
Dude,
I know so many fucking parents that dope
up their kids.
I know two parentS where their kids are
just wild.
They're crazy and the parents don't pay
much attention to the kids.
So the kids are on drugs.
I have to put the kids on some
medications.
Dogs.
People give dogs depressant.
So fucking anxiety drugs and my old
neighbor,
she used to live down the street from me
and you know,
I didn't know her that much but he was
just,
hi,
how you doing?
What's going on?
And her kid was,
you know,
always running around and you know,
playing fucking dragons and swords like
kids,
do you know,
I was kinda gotta get them on something.
There's something wrong with my baby.
I'm like,
there's nothing wrong with your kid as a
kid when kids are fucking four and you
work all day and you come home,
they're wired to the gills.
Okay.
no one's watching what they're eating or
eating candy all day and they want to go
crazy and go nutty.
You're just old.
You forgot what it's like to be a five
year old.
This is how five year olds are.
They're fucking crazy.
Five year old boys are crazy and she had
them doped up and then this other lady I
know,
same fucking thing or kid was wild.
He was running around crashing cars into
everything.
She's like,
something wrong with them.
I got to take him to the doctor.
I'm like,
there's nothing wrong with a fucking kid
fucking kid.
So she's got them doped up to,
you know,
it's like jay jeffrey.
It's amazing that that's even an option.
Jim jeffrey
said his mom used to wake them up every
morning with a glass of orange juice and
ritalin and she would just open up,
like he said,
he didn't even know what it was.
She'd just be like open up and just pop
them in his mouth and make them drink it
down.
Well,
you know,
when you develop a kid incorrectly,
some people are just mentally
imbalanced.
That is a fact.
There's some people that their hormone
levels are the chemical levels of the
brand or just fucked up and they do need
some help,
but there's other people that just were.
Somebody raised them shitty,
just did a terrible job,
barely fucking paid attention to him and
the kid developed all this nutty
behavior and getting it out of someone.
It's way harder to get something out of
something.
Someone once it's in there,
once they've already developed some
wacky patterns of behavior and they have
like certain associations,
very difficult to get that to change,
but if you could just,
you know,
it's way easier to raise on correctly
from the beginning to try to turn
someone around once they're fucked up.
It'S like how many people that you know,
that are a mess,
that have fucked up lives ever.
Pull it together ever.
You know,
ever so few,
but so few people quit anything.
I know a chick who used to prostitute
herself and she was like the nicest girl
in the world.
I knew two girls that kinda like went to
prostitution and they,
you wouldn't think either these girls,
but she was doing like craig little
craigslist hooking and shit and um,
she had,
you know,
it had like the molestation thing and
all that fucked up stuff and she went to
therapy and jay and I said,
why don't you tell what your therapist
say about it?
And she's like,
I don't tell them.
I'm like,
well,
you need to tell your therapist that you
were molested and all this stuff and
work on that shit.
And she did eventually and she's like
married and I think she's had in her
life is good.
It,
she really is a product of like,
it actually cleaned up that problem.
people can do it,
man.
You can change it.
Just you've got to be fucking goddamn
committed staying on that track.
You almost have to become addicted to
changing,
you know,
you have to like get and it has to get
ingrained in you so deeply after so long
a time that it actually becomes your new
way of thinking and you new behavior.
I mean,
if you just go back and look at
yourself.
I mean,
if I had to be myself at 21,
I couldn't imagine if I had my 21 year
old brain today,
I would be fucking insane out of
nothing.
I would never,
I would have liked the house on fire
with fucking to drive my cars over
cliffs.
I mean,
I feel like last night what happened in
my house,
I had my 21 year old brand.
You guys hAd some nutty as podcast on.
Fuck,
I'm going to ask you.
I'm afraid to go to my house.
It's so you never finished what happened
to you?
Um,
in the most recent pot thing where you
send me a message?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
I was in New Zealand and um,
uh,
I,
I had smoked a few times.
Our arch barker and I are really good
friends.
And when we're Australia we go to his
house and we just,
and he's another guy that's huge in
Australia.
Massive.
He's in Australia.
He's like,
chris rock isn't America?
Yes.
Wow.
Uh,
like,
like dane cook.
Yeah.
That massive.
Like,
like crazy sells every ticket he puts
out.
And I've heard of them in America.
He's funny is,
but it's cartoon
that we love our gcp fucking hilarious.
And uh,
it,
it.
And he was doing well in America.
He's on flight of the conchords,
you know,
he's got a career here.
Yeah.
It's not that he's doing bad,
but just superstar superstar there.
And he loves it and it's a great place.
He splits his time there.
No,
he's there now.
Permanently.
Yeah.
It's so crazy.
He said fuck it.
He bought this great house up in the
middle of like,
it's out there and he's got a farm and
he just loves it now.
You're a huge in Australia too,
but you want to be over here more?
Yeah,
I'd much rather be here.
Why is that?
Just,
you know,
I've got family here and stuff and
getting back the 15 hour flights.
not easy.
It's brutal.
It is brutal to fucking crush you.
The crusher spirit that I fly.
I've got,
you have to throw it in three weeks.
I'm going in.
I'm done too.
Are you going to be in,
in town?
Um,
I leave sydney like the day you show up.
Oh really?
Shit dude.
I could hook you up.
What's,
what's,
what,
what days?
You're um,
um,
I got two shows because the first show
sold out you at the end.
And morgan?
No,
no I couldn't get in there.
There was a band because the ufc,
the what happens is the ufc books their
stuff kinda like late in comparison to
like stand up and concerts.
Like if you go to a concert venue,
most concert venues are booked six
months to a year out.
So for ufc it's not that far out.
Like we're,
we don't and we haven't announced yet.
We got some shit announce right now.
It's in april,
but there's some still some stuff in
marx's up in the air and the may stuffs
up in the air and the june stuff is up
in the air.
Some of them get confirmed and some of
them are still up in the air.
And the problem is sometimes I don't
find out until like maybe the latest,
the earliest is three months out,
three months out.
It's tough to get a gig because they're
all,
all the venues are booked friday and
saturday nights.
So it's saturday night and met rudy
hill,
wherever that is that he rooty hill rsl.
Hey,
I know it.
I know supposedly in a funky,
I think you,
you must be,
is a list promoting,
uh,
the same people that promoted the last
time.
So those are my guys.
Yeah,
they're great.
Yeah.
Same guys pack that place.
Yeah,
sort of the first one is already sold
out in the second one.
And by the way,
if you want to go to mandalay bay this
weekend,
it's almost sold out friday night.
Um,
uh,
at the mandalay bay theater and uh,
there's gonna be a,
it's going to be arusha fear and joe
dhea,
so it's going to be fucking crazy.
It's a big giant place,
but I've been pimping the tickets for a
long time so it's almost sold out.
So,
um,
this is the place I'm doing it.
SYdney as the rsl club.
You ever,
were you ever working on?
Yeah,
I think there's a good.
yeah,
yeah.
You're like,
it's an rsl ourselves,
like they're retired service league,
which means it's like they're veterans
clubs until it's like a vfw.
Your plane.
So how come you didn't tell me to get
the fuck out of the neighborhood?
You think you think you're like,
fuck,
I'm playing a vfw,
be in that place.
They'll have a big fucking,
it must be pretty big.
What's it?
The capacity?
I think it's like $800.
So I have like the theater within there,
like,
but in every little town they have these
rsls and it's where you go to drink
cheap before you go out at night and
they got poker machines club.
Yeah.
So what,
but why are they tellIng me to get out
of town?
Because it's probably a.
They sent us a shitty neighborhood.
Yeah.
They're like,
if you're going to party,
don't party there.
I get the fuck out of there.
Get back into the city.
Why is it creepy?
It's just a fucking suburb.
It's like playing like,
you know,
like if you were in clifton,
clifton,
New Jersey and you're not.
and sometimes it's fun being in the
suburbs.
So sometimes it's fun being those weird
fringe places.
Well they've got,
you know,
they're,
they're rednecks are called bogans
bogans slogan.
So they're like,
I'm crocodile dundee is that they're
more like,
um,
they're guys that are In delight,
nitro circus kind of shit.
They'd call,
they'd call them like circuit does that
mean nitro circus?
That mtv show with pat?
Uh,
travis pastrana have no idea the
motorcycle motorcycle jumping and all
that.
So they're just like,
fucking,
you know,
guys like to have fun and adventure
seekers.
A lot of guys in Australia fucking ride
motorcycles and they drove units which
are like pickup trucks.
I'll start as a goddamn manly country,
yet extremely goddamn mentally.
Was that about,
was it the prison colony thing?
I think it has a lot to do with that
task to fucking beautiful place,
man.
Australia.
So gorgeous.
And,
and I Saw like I saw down there and the
surfers,
they're just crush americans are really.
Every dude there.
You think he's a pro real,
you'll just go to like some guy like,
hey,
you do you serve?
And he'll be like,
hey,
I did a little and you want to go
tomorrow?
You'll go to the next day and be like,
dude,
you should be on tour.
Like really fucking all amazing.
Well they love the ufc.
Mma and ufc sells out there in like 15
minutes time every,
every single time we've been there.
We've been there twice,
but every single time it breaks,
records sells out quicker than anything.
It's fucking nutty.
And they love george sada apolis there.
One guy that got a little,
one famous australian guy.
He's a fucking great dude.
Yeah,
he's a top contender right now in the
ufc.
Two nicest fucking guy in the world,
but he's a perfect ozzy just so fucking
savage.
They have a,
they have a real fucking like they call
theM blokes,
like a guy's a bloke and they're very
blokey and women complain about it.
Like in sydney,
I always say that like,
you can't even talk to a woman in a bar
because the guys have fucked them over
so badly.
You go up to go and be like,
hi.
She was like,
go fuck yourself can't.
And You're like,
whoa,
what did I do?
And it's not like you did.
It's what the last 20 guys that dealt
with her did.
So the girls are on the defensive and
uh,
because the guy is just,
it's all about your boys,
but don't they have a different attitude
towards sex and Australia?
The much more permissive?
Much more.
I would say there are a lot of much
musculus everywhere.
But America,
that's one thing you don't realize about
America.
How,
I mean obviously the middle east is
worse unless you're a little boy,
but in the,
in the middle east,
they love to fuck little boys.
That's,
that's an awesome time for them,
but as far as like like european
countries,
we are so fucked up in comparison to
them like our,
our whole repression,
all that shit that doesn't exist over
there.
They're like in Argentina and south
America,
the commercials,
there's super life hurt.
I've heard,
I don't know how true this is.
I read or it was in a.
It was a statistic in jesus camp.
Did you see that film?
They said two thirds of americans born
again.
Christians know that's what it said in
the beginning of that film.
I don't think that's correct.
I think probably two thirds of the
people that they talked to or
evangelical,
you know,
finding the numbers of for $300,
million people.
that's so problematic.
Not only that,
you've got to add in mexicans,
you know,
because there's a lot of undocumented
people in this country and who knows how
many it is.
I mean,
I've heard millions and millions in
California alone,
so who knows how many it is nationwide,
so knowing how many people are actually
christians and evangelical evangelical
christians or people who believe the
earth is less than 10,000
years old.
You know the numbers are.
Who the fuck knows what they are?
I've heard 51 percent believed the earth
is less than 10,000
years old.
Fifty one percent believe in a biblical
version of the bible that's fucked up
there.
But which by the way,
play that fucking clip.
Yeah.
god,
we have to play this clip.
Bill O'reilly,
man.
Now,
by the way,
bill o'reilly went to fucking harvard.
I also think he's a troll.
I think he's playing a character.
I think you might be wrong.
Almost pause.
Thank.
He's,
uh,
he's very clever as to lIke the kind of
shit that he supports in the way
supports.
It is so asinine that it's almost like
he's trolling.
It's almost like subtle parody.
Yeah.
Here's why I think that I used to do
sports radio in New York city.
I was on w new,
which is the station,
opie and anthony.
Ron And all that,
I was the morning show with this guy
named sid rosenberg's sids.
Sure.
I know.
Said rosenberg.
I do a show in miami all the time.
Sports expert.
I knew fucking nothing.
It waS supposed to be like love lines
where he was the expert and I was the
comedian and sid wanted me to be an
expert in sports and I don't give a shit
about,
you know,
what fucking guy stats.
So did he ask you to like learn the
stats?
No,
but there was constant conflict between
the two of us because you worked there
for six months and I was like,
I'm getting the fuck out of here.
So he was telling you,
hey,
read the sports book,
read it.
You'd be like,
did you watch the game last night?
And like,
no.
And he's like,
why not?
I'm like,
I didn't fucking want to fucking be
funny.
I'll be funny.
And he's like,
but you got to be funny about sports.
I'm like,
no,
I don't.
I just have to be funnY.
So man,
that always bugs me when I listen to
sports radio.
And they were like,
and how bout mchenry with the play in
the night?
Does he think that dad's gonna get his
contract extension but don't bump.
But it made me fucking like crazy
because I realized the only way you're
going to get ratings and be interesting
is I had to basically take on a
character and I would sit there and
criticize these athletes and these
coaches that I didn't even watch the
fuck below to that.
By the way,
I wouldn't even watch the game.
And I'd be like,
jim fossil,
he's a fucking pussy.
Did you see what he did?
Just say fuck,
I wouldn't say that,
but I'd be like,
can you put.
I said pussy.
I'd go,
he's a pussy,
he's a pussy.
And the next thing you know,
you know,
all his fans are called,
I'm going to kick your roads,
man.
How could you say that?
How could it.
And I would just try to incite people to
create radio.
And I watch fucking bill o'reilly and
I'm like,
he's doing the same shit.
There's no possible way he might be.
He,
you know,
I definitely think he's playing towards
his market.
He has a market and he's concocted this,
this gigantic conglomeration of retards
and old people
that think that he makes sense,
but this is one of the most troll like
things that he's ever said.
BrIan,
check this out.
It's talking about the moon is on bill
o'reilly dot com.
Could find on youtube backstage
conversation backstage with bill
o'reilly,
david,
beverly hills,
Florida,
or what do you mean when you refer to
the ties?
When you asked about the existence of
god?
Science explains the tides.
The moon's gravity pulls on the ocean.
Okay,
I had pneumonia then.
How'd you get there?
look,
you pinheads who attacked me for this?
You guys are just desperate.
Had sImone get there.
I just wanted to get there.
I get there.
Can you explain that to me?
How come we have that and maurice
doesn't happen.
Venus doesn't happen.
How come mars has two moons by now?
How'd I get here?
How did that little amoeba get here?
Cool out there.
How to do it?
Come on.
You have order in this universe.
You have an order in the universe.
Tide comes in,
tide goes out.
Okay.
Yeah,
the moon does it fine,
and the moon get there.
Who put it there?
It just happened.
Okay.
If we have existence,
if we have life on earth,
how come they don't have it on the other
plants?
We just lucky some media and do this.
Come on.
you know,
I see this stuff.
It's desperate times.
It takes more faith to not believe and
just think that this was all luck.
EverY oldest human body,
the intricacies of it and everything
else,
all luck.
Then It does it to believe in a deity.
Is there a positive I want you to do
right now?
Two things I want you to do.
One,
I want you to go look up a bill
o'reilly,
a scandalous voicemails because he left
a bunch of voicemails on his assistance.
His assistant's fallen about a rubbing
her down with a loofa sponge and fucking
all kinds of creepy shit.
He wound up payIng her off,
don't you?
Don't you think that bill o'reilly's the
kind of guy that really needs to get
really high?
Yeah,
and then he might go,
holy shit back.
I take back almost everything I've ever
said.
She,
yeah,
for sure he would because he would allow
hIm a different perception that he
probably has never entered into if he
does believe that shit,
but it's,
I don't know if he does or doesn't.
I think he does and this is why I think
he does.
I think he does because he's got a
tremendous ego and I think,
you know,
he's one of those guys that he's,
he's saying something all the time.
I don't think you would say something
all the time unless he believed it,
you know,
this,
this whole thing.
I think,
you know,
I think he's definitely preaching to the
choir and I definitely think he's,
you know,
trying to fit a,
fit a mold and,
and trying to appease his constituents,
all the people that listen to his show.
But I think there's,
it can't be contrary to what he really
believes because he's got too big of an
ego for him to be on tv talking about it
all the time.
Eventually he'd implode.
He wouldn't be able to deal with that.
If you really did have a,
an intelligent
argument that was contrary to what we've
saying,
I don't think you would be saying it on
the air.
I just think his ego's too big.
I don't think he's that genius.
He's not.
He's not andy kaufman and he's not some
brilliant trickster that's fucking
fooling the world.
I think these guYs,
they start playing a character and then
they sort of like dice clay it.
They become the character.
Yeah.
Whatever one dice clay onto the dice.
Clay used to be andrew silverstein,
by the way.
We're goIng to try to get dice on the
podcast too.
I'm not hating.
I love dies down a great talk with dice.
Ella.
Date diocese.
Kid is doing comedy.
Dices kid is 20 and diocese so proud and
his kid is fucking killing.
It's kids like learning.
Yeah,
and it's fucking great.
what's his name?
What's he go by?
What's his name was max.
Max.
Max clay.
No,
I don't think goodby silverstein.
Anyway,
he'd seen his name around dice used to
be a andrew silverstein and then he
would.
The dice man was like this character
that he would do on stage along with a
bunch of other characters.
He would do like stallone and he would
do deniro.
He would do like all these characters,
like all these impressions and the dice
man was one of his characters.
Well,
the dIce man just became his main
character that became his thing.
He done on stage and then it became him
offstage.
You know,
and I think that happens to guys like
Glenn Beck.
I think what happens is they start out
with this character and they start out
and then they get all these people.
Thank you,
Mr.
Beck.
You make me so happy.
And what you said about jesus is so
important to me and my family and what
you say about our troops so important to
me and our family and he,
this guy's soaking in this love and he's
putting out a book every three days.
This motherfucker and all of them are
about what's wrong with the left and
what's wrong with society and what's
wrong with being godless and what's
wrong with this.
And sarah palin's the only hope for our
country,
and then they start fucking believe in
it,
man,
because the human ego,
when you're the type of person that's
really selling something and pitching
something and getting all this adulation
for it,
if you're an egomaniac,
which most people get into the public
eye are,
you know,
most people that get into a position
where like a guy like that where they
have a,
an opinion show where they're onstage
every day talking to people and
broadcasting to millions.
They get all this love and fan mail.
It's very difficult to be objective
about that.
You know,
it's very difficult to like,
you know,
have a real honest way of looking at the
way you start looking at it the way they
want you to look out.
Because this is where the love's coming
from.
You know,
and then you start back turned into a
fucking mormon.
Okay?
As an adult,
as an adult,
who by the way is obviously,
look,
you can say he's crazy and I do,
but that has got a high iq.
There's no question in my mind.
I guarantee you,
if you sat that guy down,
he's won 20 Plus iq,
you know,
he's a smart guy.
There's no way you could do that.
Free ball mormonIsm,
he's fucked up.
No,
he's not.
Look,
the,
the intelligence and balance are two
totally different things.
I've met some brilliant people.
I'm one of the,
I don't want to say his name,
a guy who used to design my website so
fucking brilliant,
but completely insane and totally
imbalanced.
I know a bunch of people like that,
that are really,
really brilliant people,
but I mean mathematically brilliant,
you know,
structurally brilliant,
brilliant.
The way they can break down a complex,
uh,
orders in all,
in their own life is just chaos.
And you're saying becky is brilliant.
Yes.
I think he's absolutely brilliant.
Brilliant.
And being a cunt,
he's what he's doing is I think he's a
brilliant manipulation.
Yeah,
brilliant manipulation,
brilliant at acting,
brilliant at playing apart,
brilliant at becoming the perfect
version of this guide thAt all these
retards need.
Because I don't,
I don't think it takes intelligence to
be a manipulator.
What he's doing takes intelligence.
He's free balling every day.
He's got like a big screen and is
breaking things down and some of it
makes sense.
It's like 20 or 30 percent of it.
I go,
god dammit.
I agree with glen beck.
This is ridiculous.
But I think that those guys,
when they get to that position where the
extraordinary amount of success that
they achieve in one certain area meet
glenn beck's houses for sale in
Connecticut and I looked at that shit
online.
There's a fucking giant and it's
probably only for sale because he got a
bigger one.
You know,
you've got a bigger crazier when that
guy selling.
Literally every time I go to the
bookstore there's a new Glenn Beck book
and nobody makes me feel lazier than
glenn bUck because I've been writing
this god damn book for a year and I
can't ha Glenn Beck putS out one every
15 days.
It's fucking insane,
you know.
But these guys,
I really truly believe as a person who's
been affected by fame and had been
affected like my war.
If I had to look at my own behavior and
analyze it and then you know,
that's one of the reasons why I really
got into psychedelics and the,
the isolation tank is because I felt
like there was an overwhelming influence
that that fame and the pursuit of fame
has on a person,
especially in hollywood where you're,
you're trying to make things happen
where you can lose yourself in this
quest and I take it happens to a lot of
people.
So I wanted to kind of analyze it in
myself and,
and it took a long time for me to get
ahold of it from like fear factor on.
There was like a long time in there
where I was like,
this is a crazy thing here.
Like how do you make sure that what
you're doing is really what you want to
be doing?
How do you,
how do you,
how do you know that you know what
you're doing is not what you think
people would like to hear from you or
what you think is gonna you're gonna say
and do to get more work and to get more
people to like you.
I mean,
I've had conversatIons with really
successful people.
They say,
you know,
I can't do that because I'm this and
that and my image is that and this and
like,
okay,
you're,
you're not even doing you,
you're pretending to be something else
just so that you can get more of the
positive reaction that you've gotten.
That permeates into your real life,
but what if,
what if that's like,
like I'm the kind of person I vacillate.
Often I'll,
I'll look at one thing and then all have
a different opinion maybe a year later
on how I felt about it and been in the
seat and as a,
as a performer,
as a comedian,
my ax constantly changing.
Sometimes I can't do bits that I used to
do because I've changed as a person.
I don't feel that way and I can't
deliver them with truth and I'm like,
that would suck to fucking be locked
into accounts.
We're off air Says we're off the air use
drink keeps on fucking up,
but it's on here.
It says we're on here,
so it's going off and on and it's choppy
for people,
but I can't get on right now.
It's on you see it.
Yeah,
it's on.
You see online.
Where do you see online?
We have 13,
17 viewers.
It's broadcasting.
It's recording.
See if you can see it on a.
On a browser.
All right.
Anyways,
who cares?
We're talking about use you,
you know.
Well,
I'm just my.
I accidentally unclicked it and I can't
get back to.
Sorry,
go ahead.
So people lIke that,
the ability to like change while you're
and to get locked into that character
would be terrifying for me.
I'm a control freak and if that's where
your income and I don't have the,
you know,
I'm lucky enough that I don't have like
a life and kids.
But imagine if you got into that where
then you've got a house and mortgages
and schools and you've,
you've bought into this character and
all of a sudden you've changed as a
character and you're like,
fuck,
I'm not that guy anymore.
I don't feel that way.
I've changed my way of thinking,
but fuck,
I gotta I gotta still do that because
people do change.
People either become more conservatIve
as they get older or you know,
start to realize shit,
you know,
I've become more liberal as I get older.
Yeah,
yeah.
Well,
I think as you become more intelligent,
you know,
you realize that there's a lot more.
There's a lot more to things than people
think.
Now.
Everybody likes to think it's black and
white.
I have a lot of conservative now,
a lot of them about gun control,
about,
uh,
about taxes,
about a lot of different things.
But I also have a lot of liberal points
of view to,
you know,
especially when it comes to things like
gay marriage and,
you know,
and that to me is one of the most
frustrating things when I see people get
upset about gay marriage,
you know,
as if it's somehow another fucking
effects.
You have two guys who obviously want to
be gay.
No one's got a gun to their head.
No one's saying,
if you're not gay,
I'm fucking killing your family.
You know?
No one's doing that.
They're just,
I find the people that are afraid of
life,
bro.
This shit is offline,
man.
It's on everyday.
I can take it on.
You know,
I,
it's,
it's having pro ustream.
Ustream has some problems,
man,
when there's like you're trying to get
on it,
you have to refresh it a few times,
whatever.
It's on those,
so don't worry about it.
That's crazy.
I,
I walked out of the.
Actually it was when I worked with you
down in tampa or I was doing the,
the early and then you did like friday
night and you came in tampa improv.
I came out like my first night,
it was like a wednesday or something and
they're these guys out in the street
holding up signs and it was like almost
like that church from Nebraska or
wherever.
Those crazy fuckers that protest
funerals is that.
And they were holding up signs,
god hates fags and blah blah blah.
And I just walked out.
So the audiences out there with me and I
thought I'm just going to fuck with
these people.
And I went up to this kid and I'm like,
how old are you?
And he's like,
I'm 16 years old.
I'm like,
you're 16 and you're to go to an arcade.
Go try to get laid.
Go fucking have a life the fuck's wrong
with you.
Don't listen to your parents.
They're assholes.
And I'm making everybody laugh.
Just making fun of this kid.
But then I started,
some older guy starts yelling at me and
I go,
dude,
stop.
You want to caulk in your ass so badly.
Was the old guy your here right now
because you hate yourself.
I'm like,
you want to make it easy?
Just go suck a cock.
It's going to change your whole life.
You're out here,
you're doing this shit because you're a
homo and you just don't want to admit
it.
And I'm like,
leave them the fuck alone.
And go join them.
That's your deep down.
You know you're gay.
And he's like,
you're the devil.
You're the devil.
You're here to.
And I'm like,
no,
I'm here to help you.
Dude.
Go fucking suck a cock.
It's going to change your life.
I'm not joking.
The next night I walk out,
it's the atheists holding up signs
going.
You know,
there is no god and god is bad and god
created,
you know,
there's death and bob and I go up to
them and I go,
you're just fucking bad.
Just fucking shut up and go fucking have
a beer somewhere.
You're.
Why are you out of here with a.
You've got your own religion of atheism.
Like,
I get it.
I get your belief.
You know,
I don't believe in any kind of fucking
order,
anything.
I don't know what I believe,
but go away.
Fucking stop your religion of people
want to believe anything.
Whether it's they want to believe in
republicans.
They want to believe in god.
They want to believe in.
No god.
I've had arguments with acs where it's
so ridiculous.
You know,
like they're,
they're saying scientists.
Science disproves the existence of god.
Like,
no,
it doesn't scientists and disprove
anything.
What what science does is it shows it's.
Well,
first of all,
it's statistics and things that can be
measured.
You know,
how can you measure what happens in the
afterlife?
That's nonsense.
How can you measure what happened with
the birth of the universe is and how do
you mean?
How do we not know that there's
something that's far more comp?
I mean,
I'm not saying that there's a guy in the
clouds with a harp,
but what I am saying is it after smoking
dmt seven times and doing mushrooms,
all the times I've done and all the
times in the isolation tank,
I've seen shit way crazier than a dude
with a harp and the clouds.
Okay.
And I've seen it many,
many,
many times.
I,
I think that the idea that you can tell
me what does and doesn't exist is
fucking ridiculous.
I cannot believe people actually try to
do that.
And I'm like,
how do we know that we're here right
now?
Or that were,
you know,
there could be something so complex.
I always tell people when they go,
what's your belief on god?
I go,
when my dog looks at my computer,
my mac book,
she can't comprehend the operating
system she has.
No.
She does not have the capability.
And I believe that as humans,
that's how we are with the universe.
We don't have the fucking capability,
we might be the most intelligent
species,
but we're not intelligent enough to
understand something that's doesn't mean
anything.
It's like being the baddest worm.
This worm is so smart.
He knows how to get around this pebble,
you know,
it's really,
it's ridiculous.
The idea that we can figure it out.
I mean,
this is complete and total stoner talk,
but the idea that we can figure out the
fucking universe,
you know.
Did you find the bill o'reilly?
I'm the stuff now.
It's not on there.
What's not a video,
bro?
So on a video,
it's an audio.
Well,
I think they just transcribed it.
I saw it on a Washington post and stuff,
but it just kind of talked about it.
Did they have the transcriptions though?
Hey,
I want to change the subject for said,
did you Bobby Leon here yesterday did to
get naked for you.
Fuck it.
It got on our podcasts and we could not
get him to keep his clothes on.
He was just fucking rubbing his dick on
everything and wow.
So fucking much more sedate and what you
guys fed them over there?
Uh,
I think he was,
you know,
I can,
have you ever told your story
that you did at the storyteller a
anywhere else other than that show?
That was the first time I ever told him
you should talk with,
uh,
the whole,
the whole time we use that urban,
all of the black show.
You want to tell that story?
I'm not afraid.
I mean,
it's not,
it's not racist on my part with apps not
just took a chance.
Yeah.
I,
I went to a suny,
it was called suny farmingdale.
It was a state university of New York in
farmingdale,
long island.
And uh,
my manager at the time,
I think I'd only been doing comedy maybe
three years,
three or four at the most.
I was in New York city and my manager at
the time,
jason steinburge.
Do you know jason?
Yes.
Jason.
And I'm only telling you his name
because I want to burn them on this.
Jason at the time had mostly black
comics and all it's comics were like def
jam didn't doing really well.
And so like some great great comics he
had,
he represented a lot of really good
guys.
Tony woods,
greer barnes,
all these guys were doing really well
time and we're big in that.
Like so he was always booking these
events for like black shows and I get a
c,
I'm begging for work because I don't
have any work at the time.
And I hear him,
I'm in his office,
I hear him go,
oh,
oh yeah,
so you need a comment yet yet?
And it's not a def jam show,
right?
Ensure.
Yeah.
Okay.
I think I got the 500 bucks and I'm like
500 bucks.
Fuck,
that's the most I've ever gotten paid
for a gig.
And I was like,
I want this fucking gig.
And he goes,
all right,
you're going to have to.
Suny farmingdale train takes you right
out there.
It'll be like $10 train ride.
He's like,
it's your,
you're the intermission of an auction.
And I'm like,
what?
He's like,
yeah,
it's traditionally,
this is like an urban room,
but it's just this auction.
It's going to be like alumni and stuff.
And I'm like,
all right.
I will,
I go out there on the way out.
Tony woods.
Do you know tony?
Tony and I are sharing and somebody
who's really good friend of mine,
he's going,
dog,
don't fucking go dog.
They beat up Ralph Harris.
They beat him up on stage and I'm like,
what?
He's like,
they're gonna kill you guys.
Sam the hog don't go,
so why don't you listen is 500 bucks.
I go,
no,
but it's an auction.
It's different.
I'm in the intermission.
It's an alumni thing.
So I go,
I get there.
I see the line of people waiting to go
in and it's not just an urban show.
This is fucking like urban.
Tony told me,
he goes,
dude bro.
He goes there,
their caribbean,
black,
caribbean,
black are the guys that they killed me
because I'm american black.
He's like,
they're gonna fuck you up.
And I'm like,
no,
no.
He's like,
trust me.
So I see the line of guys going in.
Everybody's gone on fubu,
you know,
like jerseys and timberlands.
Every single dude in the crowd,
baggy jeans by the way of fubu stands
for,
for us,
by us.
And unlike funches,
you know,
kinda like separatist as it is and it's
pretty funny when joey diaz whereas
that.
Yeah,
sure.
So I go,
this is how long ago this was,
I go to the payphone and r and r I page
jason steinburge,
and he calls me on the payphone and I
go,
jason,
I'm fucking outta here.
I'm outta here.
And he goes,
you're fine,
you're fine.
It would just be funny.
I'm like,
no,
this doesn't look good.
He goes,
no,
you're gonna be fine.
So I go into the auditorium.
Security goes,
well,
what are you doing?
I go,
I'm the comedian.
Security goes,
fuck,
you're the comedian.
I quit because I'm outta here about here
because he knows what's going to happen.
The security guys saw you as a black
guy.
That was.
Yeah.
And he said,
he just says,
fuck,
this was serious.
It was serious.
They call this gig the little apollo.
Oh my god.
And so I'm like,
fuck.
So I go back to the phone.
I called jason again.
I go,
jason,
I'm leaving,
I'm leaving.
I'm just not doing it.
I'm going to die.
He's like,
eddie,
you're funny.
He's like,
just get up there and do what you do.
And I'm like,
so I,
I'm so nervous,
you know,
when you're so new there's no chance of
you doing well and awkward.
So I go down and the,
the mc goes,
uh,
what do you,
what do you want to come out to?
And I never come out to music before.
I'm like,
what do you mean you got any led zepplin
free bird,
you know,
like fuck,
like a puff the magic dragon.
I don't fucking know what.
And they've got a dj on the side and I'm
like,
fuck.
And come out too.
Well I don't follow any rap music.
Right?
All at the.
Especially at that time I came from a
place called fox chapel and I would come
out to fuck the police.
I didn't know what that.
And at the time I think knight rider is
a good one.
I had the shitty nightrider joke about
how kid was gay.
It was a gay car because they like l or
ellen at the time was like coming out
and I go,
she's not the first gay character kit
from nightrider was gay and uh,
it made me.
He's like,
michael,
I'm going to pick you up in a minute.
And uh,
so I was like,
I'll do the kitchen and I'll come out to
the knight rider like rap song by the
way.
Get our kelly the zoo,
get that,
pull that shit up.
I know.
We'll just,
we'll edit it out later.
Do you need,
we need this,
just trust me.
Just pull it up on the side.
So I go backstage and what they're doing
is they're auctioning off dates with
students from the school,
so girls or guys like a guy will come
out and heal and all the dudes are
backstage lifting,
doing foot pumping up,
doing pushups and they've got dumbbells.
So they're,
they're getting swole and they're
putting baby oil all over their bottles
and taking their shirts off.
And they're black as tar.
Yeah.
And they are no one ever making them
black.
Everyone's ignoring me.
Like what the fuck are you doing back
here?
And I swear to god I grabbed one of the
bottles of rum that they're drinking and
I just start chugging rum because I'm
like,
this is.
I'm terrified so I shouldn't.
I just start scrolling down this rum and
there.
I saw one chick there,
the one white chicken.
I'm like,
she's really fucking hot.
So they're auction dates with the guys
and the girls.
The guys will come out,
they'll just like flex and everybody
will bid and then the girls will come
out and do like a strip tease act.
They'll bring a guy,
I'll put them in a chair and grind on
them and do like a lap dance or whipped
cream and do all this shit,
you know?
And they'll go crazy,
but they're bidding.
They get dinner at puff daddy's
restaurant.
P diddy had a restaurant in New York.
They had dinner at his place.
They get a limo ride to New York and a
broadway show.
If they win the date and they're
bidding.
And I swear to god,
dates are going for like $7 and watch
five sold.
Who could,
you know know,
and I'm looking at the hot fucking white
chick going,
I want a bit,
we'll backstage this and she has to go
out on a date with a guy.
Hey,
the guys just discussed it.
Well,
this is where it gets creepy.
So the finale,
I'm going to be the intermission.
Then the finales is black stripper and
she comes up to me and she said,
hey,
you're the comedian.
I'm like,
yeah,
she's like,
my name's heaven.
And I'm like,
hey heaven.
And so we start talking.
She goes,
you're going to stick around and bid on
me.
And I'm like,
and she thinks I'm like this
professional,
you know,
rich comedian and I'm going to be able
to bid a lot of money.
And because you told her that,
I don't know,
I'm like,
I can't think about her.
She starts talking to me.
I just want to get a little taste.
I actually said to her,
get away from me because I was so scared
because all the guys were checking her
out and I'm like,
I just don't want any problems here.
So you thought you were going to get
problems because you were talking to the
bikes in front of black,
kind of given you the mad dog look.
So I'm just like,
I'm just going to fuck.
So has anybody said anything to any
guys?
No one was just white fear.
They forget.
Total has been negative to you.
Got it.
You got to understand,
I grew up in a place where there was
like my high school probably had like
one black guy and you know,
his last name was huxtable and uh,
we,
I ran track all through college and I
was a sprinter,
but I was separate,
like I didn't hang out.
I hung out with my white friends and I
wasn't.
So when I moved to New York and I
started to become friends with all the
black comics,
it was like a total new world for me.
But this was like putting me in.
I was out of my comfort zone.
So what's your opening line?
My opening line,
I,
I miss my cue to go out and they're
yelling for me.
Oh god.
And I've rewritten all my jokes.
You know,
when you do that,
I read and I go as not good.
I'm not confident in this.
And I like stumble almost trip on the
stage and they're already.
The emc had been go where my dogs at and
goes,
ooh.
And they're running to the front of the
stage when he does it and all putting
their hands up in the air and I come out
and I go,
hey,
uh oh,
what happened before I came out?
They auction off the white chick,
right?
The bidding goes up to like $350 and
every black chicken,
the place is about to fucking rush the
stage stabber.
And I'm like,
there's going to be a ride in here and
the black church,
southern white guy.
So I'm going down with her.
So black girl saying there,
they're pissed off.
They're screaming and they're going to
get a here.
And so caner mission happens.
They call me out and I think my opening
line,
I think I said something about they're
going to be a riot when they did it on
the,
when they were bidding on the white
chick.
And I go,
you know,
I was like,
and I get a little,
I get a little bit of a laugh and there
was some creepy dude that was like an
older dude who was bidding.
I made a black guy though.
I said it's like a pedophile.
And they kind of laughed at that and
then I said,
you guys,
what are you doing with auctions?
Didn't you learn your lesson with
auction years ago?
And I think it's kind of funny and I
think like I'm going to get a laugh.
Like,
like kind of like,
oh he's an insult comic and I hear like
a womb and all of a sudden another who
and I wasn't quick enough to keep going
and I just said he paused,
I paused and then you let them just
started building.
It was like a wave of booing to started
to like get this mother fucker off the
stage and people start throwing shit.
And I swear to god,
I hear it,
get that fucking wait,
get your white motherfucker ass off the
stage before I kick your white
motherfuckers.
And I'm like standing there and I'm,
I'm kind of like in this,
like all of a sudden I get hit in the
head with a cup,
a crumpled up coke cup and he pisses me
off and I go,
who the fuck through that?
Who?
And I don't know why,
but you know,
you get that rage and it's like,
all this shit's happening to me.
And I'm like a dog.
That's been so much.
I just started biting everyone.
Who the fuck?
Who the fuck through that?
And some guy goes,
I did.
I go,
fuck you.
You want to throw something?
Come on fucking throw something at me.
Fuck.
The kids starts running towards the
stage and there are fold out chairs in
the front.
He picks one of them up and throws it on
the stage.
And unlike at that moment,
I go,
I'm going to fucking die like a.
And they're pulling cushioning out of
the seats and throwing it at me.
And they're booing so loud.
Now here's what's hilarious about eddie
left.
This is what he says to me,
that when he tells me the story at the
beginning of the day,
he goes,
now if it happened today,
I totally be able to be like,
I told the to make it funny.
Comedians always want to think that I
have so some.
I have some ruthless bombs in my past
and I have gone over these bombings and
said,
man,
if I could just go back and redo it is
one time I bombed after jim breuer
zwiers bottom of my entire career.
It was devastation.
I think I've talked about this for,
I don't remember.
I've talked about on the podcast,
didn't brewer.
We worked together all weekend and I
could barely follow them.
You know,
this is like,
I only been doing comedy maybe three
years,
maybe three or four years and he was
just too strong to the middle and I
really wasn't a headliner.
It was a fake headliner.
I like,
I could do 45 minutes,
but I would tell my jokes slow,
you know what I mean?
I couldn't,
you know,
so like when he was on stage and he's.
Bruce has been about going home and he
was being,
he was hammered and his mother turned
into a demon and it was like really loud
and really animated and he was just,
you know,
sometimes it just gets in the zone and
brewer used to get in these crazy zones.
Man.
I used to really enjoy watching him
perform because he could just,
just as physical performances,
physical,
you know,
his,
his presence on stage.
Fuck.
He just would nail it.
And this is one time man,
we had been doing all weekend,
so we'd done two shows friday,
one show saturday.
This was a late show saturday and brewer
just knocks it out of the park and there
was a bunch of shit going wrong in my
life at the time.
One,
I just torn my acl.
So it was for the first time in my life
I couldn't work out.
I've had never not worked out.
So I had all this tension that I didn't
know how to deal with,
you know,
like for me,
my,
my whole body from the time I was like,
you know,
14 years old to the time I was,
this was happening when I was 22 or 23,
my body had been designed just to
fucking to constantly be working,
constantly be exerting all this energy,
whether it's in kickboxing or wrestling
or something.
There was like,
there's this constant.
Then that was the only way I coped with
stress that was gone.
Okay.
And I had moved from New York to boston.
So no acl.
It blows out and moved to New York or
from boston to New York.
I have no friends.
I don't know anybody there.
I'm living with my grandfather and my
grandmother.
My grandmother was dying of an aneurysm.
She had an aneurysm.
They gave her 72 hours to live.
She lived for 12 years.
Okay.
And I'm staying in their old house that
they bought in 1945 and north New
Jersey,
which is now in a war zone.
I mean,
while I'm there,
the next door neighbor's door gets
broken down with a battering ram.
They arrest him for selling crack.
I mean,
no joke,
man.
It was a scary,
scary neighborhood.
It used to be an italian neighborhood.
Then it went just total total chaos.
So I'm staying in the house and my
grandma,
like,
she,
she died.
Both of them are dead now,
but back then she um,
she couldn't move.
She was completely paralyzed.
She would get bedsores and she could
feel some things and sometimes she would
just let out these soul,
like almost like she was emptying
herself of the pain and the only way to
do it was to let out this horrible
screech.
So I'd be in the house and I'd be like
wandering around,
maybe I go to the kitchen and grab
something to eat.
And here
it was like an animal,
like a wounded animal.
She couldn't die.
It just,
she was so resilient.
She had those italian peasant jeans and
she was just so fucked up,
but yet she hung in there for like 12
years.
So I'm living in this house.
Right.
And I'd just broken up with my
girlfriend and my manager,
god bless him,
great guy.
But it was back in the day where we
talked about like,
when you're not doing so well then
everybody has advice for you.
And his advice was you should dress
nice,
like,
you know,
you're a good dress.
Nice on stage.
So my stupid ass,
I'm wearing these like nice pants and a
nice belt and like a club shirt that you
would go out clubbing.
And I had a nice head of hair back then.
It was delicious and I'm wearing shiny
shoes and shit.
And I just looked like the fucking
biggest asshole.
I just looked like some club,
shithead,
some goofy italian con.
It's 22 years old.
It doesn't know anything about the
world.
Right?
And I'm onstage and,
and I fucking,
I am panicking.
I remember brewer got off stage and the
mc was good about to bring me up and I
was off stage when brewer came up.
And I remember he said,
he said,
hey,
I fucked up that.
How fun.
They're great.
And I go,
I'm going to fucking eat it.
And I remember saying it to him like,
dude,
I'm not fucking confident right now.
I'm not feeling good right now.
Oh,
you'll be fine.
You'll be fine.
And I just,
I just was not prepared.
I just went up there and I went into
flames.
Just went into one girl.
I remember what girl in the audit,
she goes,
I was just eating dick up there.
And I was editing my material and
chopping the jokes as I go along and one
girl goes,
you kinda hot,
but you're not funny.
Oh.
And there's nothing you can say when you
know that that's true.
Not that I'm kind of hot,
but that I'm not funny in another guy
goes,
you're fucking suck.
You fucking suck.
He's just big meat heads,
snap and nothing.
I could say he was right.
I fucking sucked.
I knew I fucking suck.
There was nothing I can do.
And I was supposed to do 45 minutes.
I wound up doing like 30.
I got a few laughs.
I started getting a few laughs,
but there were so shaky.
It was just the worst set ever,
the worst bombing ever.
And I still to this day,
we'll go back in my head that fucking 20
years ago,
that's my gig still to this day,
the worst one I've ever had.
And you'll go back and replay it over in
your head.
Okay.
I could've said this,
the heat that goes through your body
when you're bombing,
there's like,
people don't understand when you're
bombing,
there's a,
there's a hot flash.
You almost get hot flashes.
So I'm having it.
When the guy through the,
the,
that knocked me out of my aggression.
When the chair came up onto the stage,
I was like,
okay,
I'm not going to fight a crowd.
And uh,
and I gotta get the fuck out of here.
The girl on the side of the stage that,
that booked me is going to get off,
get off.
And I think this is,
I was supposed to do like 40 minutes and
I think I'm at 45 seconds or something
or four minutes.
I forget.
It was so short.
She's going to get off,
get off.
And I go,
this is how badly I wanted the money.
I go,
where's my check?
Oh my gosh,
from the stage,
but no one could hear me even with the
microphone there.
Bullying that loud.
I just looked aside.
I go,
where's my check?
I'm still getting paid.
And she's like,
yes,
yes.
And I went,
no,
I want to see the check.
I want to make sure while you're
onstage.
And I always was under the impression
like you have to do your time to get
paid and they're getting me off before
my time.
So are they going to like not paying?
So I want that $500 a month and I'm
going.
I was willing to stand up there for 35
minutes and take the abuse.
I wanted the money so bad.
And don't you think though that you
learn so much about those,
about your comedy from bombing?
So that just like fall to me.
Yeah,
it's the ultimate school.
Fuck you and I.
Right.
Then I said,
uh,
I go,
let me see the checks.
And they went and got the check.
That's it.
That's why I was up there four and a
half minutes.
They had to go get the check,
come back and then you got off offstage.
I get off stage and they rush me out the
back door like people around me because
they're afraid to riots going to start.
We go up the back door,
the stripper is waiting there and she
smoking weed with a couple of guys out
there and she goes,
hey,
where are you going?
And I'm like,
you didn't see what just fucking
happened?
She goes,
yeah,
that was some bullshit.
And I'm like,
so she can stick around though,
you know,
in bid on me.
I go,
are you fucking kidding me?
Kidding me?
Do you think they would have let it go?
They were,
the audience members would have forgot.
I don't know she,
but I got her phone number.
She gave me her phone number.
She said,
give me a call sometime and I get in the
car.
Do you remember?
This is like 1997 or 98 that this
happened or whatever.
The guy drives me to the train station
in a tr.
Nice in it.
In this little black triumph.
Any so fucked up.
He's been drinking so much rom and he's
driving like 100 miles an hour and I'm
going because he wants to get back and
I'm like,
dude,
slow the fuck down.
Slow the you're going to kill us.
And he goes,
man,
you suck.
He's like,
you are terrible.
And I'm like,
shut the fuck up.
And he's like,
no man,
like I've seen comedians.
You're the worst I've ever seen.
And he's driving me to the train
station.
Tell me how bad I am.
And it was a black dude.
Yeah.
And I get on the train.
It was the most racist I've ever been in
my life because I'm just looking at
every black person,
like blaming them for what happened.
But I imagine it live in your whole life
like that.
But welcome to being black.
I get home and at the time I was living
with him constantly fucking with him.
I mean,
it was like the river I learned,
right?
That,
that was a great learning experience.
I get home,
I'm living with my sister and uh,
at the time,
and this goes back to like answering
machine time,
like people had answered machines and
the cell phone.
Well I,
I,
I must've called street.
I don't even remember calling the
stripper,
but I must've because my grandfather
dies and we're on the way to my
grandfather's funeral.
We had already just done the viewing or
whatever.
When you go then from church and you go
to the cemetery,
we're going to the cemetery.
I'm in.
My dad had one of those,
like he had a cadillac I remember with a
car phone built into the car.
Nice.
And my dad,
my mom and like two of my sisters and me
and uh,
uh,
my sister decides to check her
voicemail,
uh,
the answer machine at home and puts it
on speaker and she listens to the
stripper and I swear to god it comes on
and goes.
It's like next message.
Beep.
Hi eddie.
This is heaven because stripper.
You met out at suny farmingdale itself,
a stripper.
I'm just returning your call.
My sister looks at me and goes at pap
apps.
Funeral dad's funeral.
That's hilarious.
That's great.
Don't you?
Don't you think though that you like
your comedy makes these big leaps after
these horrible,
disastrous bombings?
Yeah,
you absolutely have to go through it.
Check it,
fired up.
Even if I see like a bad review online,
like I'll read 10 great reviews of like
a show that I was at and then one guy
says,
I'm still waiting for my first love
that.
Can I just get like a little anxiety?
Like,
man,
I got to work harder.
But see I'm for one,
like one bad one will.
I think that shit's good for you.
I really do.
I'm different.
I and I don't want to blow smoke up your
ass,
but I like I've said I need good comics
to inspire me and I see so much shit
comic and I saw you one night working
out and I was like fuck,
fuck.
He's going deep.
He's going deep and he's not afraid and
he's fucking like when you're doing.
The monkeys were just a bunch of monkeys
on a rock spinning through and I'm like
fuck.
And I just went,
I gotta go home and write,
fuck,
I look like one of those lights.
Awesome.
I said to you have to show I go fuck
you.
And I like had to hurry home and start
like,
just like.
And I like to watch really good comp.
Like I'm one of these comics
I love when I get to pick my middle act.
I love to bring the best fucking
comedian I can bring.
Did I go on the road with joey diaz and
does he just show ideas?
Is the funniest guy that's ever walked
the face.
I've never laughed more at anybody ever
in my life.
Twenty three years of being a comic.
Have you ever met anybody funnier than
joey?
I mean it's like a cartoon.
He's just,
he's just explosive with energy.
Just makes you happy.
You know?
He just ridiculous.
It makes you funny or two.
He makes me funnier and funnier with our
work with joe.
That's how I feel better.
And that's how Brian Mccarthy,
I feel the same way.
But what you said,
like I saw dave chappelle once at the,
at the comedy store and I felt the same
way.
I want to go home and write.
I'm totally inspired by great comics
too.
Like I saw louis at the,
um,
at the improv and hollywood,
lucy kay and I wanted to go home and
write.
It was really great performance in
norton recently I saw norton at the cap
city and austin fucking great.
And that same feeling I want to go
right.
But I also get inspired by people who
don't like me.
Yeah.
Even fucking,
you know,
haters online.
I can get a million people who love me.
Dude is the greatest fucking show I've
ever seen.
Some amazing.
And one person who's like,
you know,
fucking hang it up,
streak two ufc.
Oh,
what bitch,
you know,
I'll get,
I'll get like fired up to.
I have to zone them,
work harder.
It gets good to zone them out.
But it's good to be humble.
I really believe.
I mean,
it's a bad feeling to have someone
negatively critique your work.
It's a terrible feeling,
but I think there's something to it
that's good for an artist.
There's something that keeps you sort of
humble and balanced,
especially in this either direct
adulation relationship that you have
with an audience.
You know,
you're immediately giving them what they
want to hear and they immediately laugh
and they tell you how much they love
you.
I mean,
you can get imbalanced by that.
You can get lazy.
I mean,
we both know comics had got fucking
super,
super lazy and one of the reasons is
like,
you know,
they're not for whatever reason,
there's not,
there's not enough balance.
You know,
they just got to a point where it was
too easy for them to many people being
nice to them and they just,
they lose it.
Know chris rock once had a really
important thing that I read where he's
talking about how he bombed really hard.
What's going on after martin Lawrence
Martin lawrence,
which I did too,
by the way,
a bunch of times at the comedy store
when I was a fucking.
When I was on hardball to show that
nobody ever saw on fox,
I would go on after a lot of guys to
comments are mitzi shore.
God bless her.
She did a tremendous amount for me early
in my career and one of the things that
she did for me,
she always put me on the most
devastating comedians in the night right
on after them,
like dice clay.
I went off to dice clay 100 times.
Richard pryor have to.
Richard pryor when he was in a
wheelchair when he couldn't even talk
for five weeks.
Every time martin lawrence would have a
set.
This is back when martin law into that
tv show.
He was all fucking destroy your.
I'd never seen an aston martin either.
Martin lawrence is in the back parking
lot with an aston martin.
I was like,
what the fuck is this thing like me and
a couple other comics like circling
around.
I was driving a volkswagen.
Sure rocco.
It's like scratching my chin.
Like what the fuck is this man?
This thing's crazy.
And martin would just devastate the main
room.
I mean devastate when martin lawrence
was in his prime,
that guy does not get enough respect
because if you go back and watch some of
his old standup,
he's just fucking
funny.
And that show,
martin do that shows that the writing
was like nonexistent,
but he carried the whole show with all
his characters and he pretended to be
women.
He's fucking funny.
I would be a backstage st just like the
brewer night.
I mean at least I had been past the
brewer thing.
Like it happened like a couple years
before that.
So I had recovered and I knew how to
like get out of the gate strong because
90 percent black audience,
you know,
and I'm just ready to go on after him
and he's crushing and then he's like,
who's coming up next?
You know,
he has to bring me up.
So martin lawrence brings me up,
you know,
he calls over to the piano guy.
Piano guy says joe rogan.
And he goes,
all right,
y'all give it up for this next comedian,
mr joe rogan,
very nice guy says,
and I just go up and eat a bag of shit
up.
Just a,
a big manure bag that you would buy like
at a fucking farm depot know,
just filled with shit.
I'm just chilling and people are getting
up in droves and leaving.
But all that stuff makes you way better.
It makes you a way better comic because
you realize you don't ever want to make
that feel,
that feeling.
It's like you feel the fire behind your
feet and it makes you run faster.
Like you're only going to run a certain
amount when you're not pushed that.
No,
I feel like it's funny.
Like you said,
sometimes I just go,
I'm shit,
I suck now,
blah blah blah.
But I don't realize that I don't have
the ability to bomb like that anymore.
I mean it can happen in a bad situation
now.
Like something really fucked up
happening.
But like I used to have to New York,
you know,
million times sde used to the seller.
She just wait and put you up after the
hardest person to,
to,
to make sure you were ready for it.
I had to tell forever,
every night in the cellar and that's all
I got so dark because patel would just.
His jokes were so amazing and so dark to
that.
It was like I had to go to a darker
place than him pick up the frequency
where he leaves.
And I remember just bombing so bad in
the seller that I would just start,
start just like,
what's the fucking freestyling,
just saying the worst things I could say
like talking about killing babies and
shit,
like trying to get out of this horrible
that I would just shock the fuck out of
the audience and it never works.
And it was like,
that never worked.
It was almost like if you go into a zone
though of like,
I'm going to pretend like they're not
here and I'm just going to just keep
saying this shit and hopefully they're
going to come around because this is so
painful.
I'm in this terrible,
terrible bomb.
But I mean I had,
like I watched you on,
what was it,
a,
any evening at the caroline's comedy
hour.
That's where I saw you first when I was
like a little kid.
I didn't even do comedy.
And I'm like watching you and you were
dirty.
I remember you and sarah were on it and
sarah was dirty and so he's a little
kid.
I'm like,
these are good comics.
These two,
these are convenient.
It was so hard for me back then.
They even come up with seven minutes of
material that I could do on tv.
I would have to sit down and go over my
shit.
I was like,
god,
I can't do that bit.
I can't do this,
but I might have had an hour of
material.
I might have had five.
I could do it.
I couldn't imagine you bombing because
of the way your act was like you had the
competence and the dirtiness and
everything.
So I was like,
this guy can't bomb.
It's not.
So you probably a lot less bombs than
I've had.
Wow.
Well,
yeah.
Was it.
Well,
you know,
I've had a bunch man.
I don't know about that.
I don't know how many you've had,
but especially the store.
I had a gang of them in the early days
when I was going on after,
you know,
like really good comics over and over
and over again.
I had a.
I had a quite a few bombings.
Yeah,
but the early days were way worse.
The open mic days were fucking brutal
because you're really not supposed to be
up there talking,
you really not good enough.
And then look,
brian has been doing standup.
He's been doing open mic nights just for
a short period of time.
So you're in that kind of zone area
where you're learning it and figuring it
out.
You're in that stage of your life where
sometimes,
you know,
I've seen you go on stage and you're
trying out new joke and it just doesn't
work and you're just fucked.
You know,
you're just stuck in this rut.
you're right there right now.
Right.
Well,
I had a horrible thing the other day
where somebody I knew a was sitting in
the front row and they thought,
oh,
this is awesome.
I,
you know,
I could say talk to brian while he's on
stage.
He said the whole time she's just like,
making me going like that,
or she like I said something like,
oh,
I just broke up with my ex.
I hate that bitch.
And she's like,
oh,
whenever you're not over her.
And like I said,
it loud enough where like,
it kept on like fucking me up and then
it just throws you off and I felt it.
I felt I felt way off my tracks,
you know,
but I didn't,
I never feel.
I haven't really felt like bomb.
Well you gave me anxiety so I had to go
on afterwards and I was like,
this bitch going to talk to me.
Fuck.
She going to talk to me too though?
Yeah.
But I don't want to.
I don't want.
I'd rather not.
You know,
people say,
oh,
you know,
you're so good with hecklers.
You must love it when people talk.
Shit.
No,
I want everybody to have fun.
I don't want to have to ruin someone's
mind.
Bob hope joke.
That one that talked a few times on the
podcast before when I did that and I was
booed and hissed.
I took off comedy for five years
to find joe.
Bob hope died.
He goes to hear bob hope died.
Yeah.
They're going to fly out his body to
entertain all the dead troops.
That's great.
It was the day he died though,
and it was like during like,
you know,
after he got some orange and I say,
what my favorite joke of yours is the
one that you're doing right now,
but your dog?
He goes,
uh,
I have a bunch of cats and dogs from
other relationships.
It's like whenever we break up,
I keep their cat,
I keep the dog.
He goes and they all have the same
personality as the girls that I was
dating.
It's really funny,
like all of them hate it when I come in
their face.
Now I break it down to each and chris
white house from Australia.
I think he's a kiwi,
but he lives in Australia and he's
really dark and really funny.
Really good job.
What's a kiwi?
A new zealander and a.
His name's chris.
When he writes jokes,
he writes a ton.
He on twitter.
He's right.
I don't know his name on twitter,
but he writes tons of jokes all the
time.
He did a joke about the crocodile
hunter.
The day the crocodile hunter died and
somebody in the audience yells out too
soon and he goes to soon.
I would have done that joke on the
fucking boat.
I said something about the crocodile
hunter when he died and I actually felt
bad about it and the reason why I felt
bad about it,
but some,
you know,
what I said was I go,
he dies,
I go,
my act gains 10 minutes.
I don't see the loss.
That's what I wrote on a message board.
And I just flippantly,
you know,
comics will say shit like that just to
fuck with each other.
Like have you ever done the open anthony
show now?
Never done great fucking show.
And it's,
everyone tries to say that like louis,
c k will say the mean is shit to norton
who will say the meaning shit to ob what
they say,
the mediumship active but it's not real.
It's like you're trying to get laughs
and someone said,
you know,
hey man,
this guy has like a family and children
with his children read that.
And I went,
oh shit.
And then I thought about it.
I'm like,
okay.
I don't even really think that I don't
even really believe that,
and I was really mad at myself because I
would have totally written a crocodile
hunter bit if it wasn't for the fact
that I felt bad that I wrote that I said
that,
which was our very short sighted and it
wasn't really even funny.
It was just like a quick,
easy,
cheap like jive.
And I thought about it.
I said,
god damn it,
I fucked myself out of a good crocodile
hunter because for sure that's like
right up my alley,
you know,
like I'm fucking.
No one's more fascinated by predatory
animals than me.
And when a dude who fucks with animals
his entire career,
look it.
When a guy like that fucking gets killed
by an animal,
I mean there's a,
there's a fucking wealth of material
there.
I said in earlier in Australia,
I said before he died,
uh,
I watched the show.
I go,
I mean,
they all think America loves the
crocodile hunter.
They think we all do,
but it wasn't like,
because they're not as into them as we
are.
Really.
No,
not at all.
They all kind of think he's a freak and
they're not that australians have a
thing about australians who become
famous somewhere else.
It's called tall poppy syndrome.
They,
uh,
they try to cut down the tall flower you
because jeffrey's was pissed because he
would go back to Australia and people
wouldn't buy tickets to a show,
you know?
He's like,
I've got a fucking.
Hbo is bash it.
It's my worst.
Jeffrey,
he doesn't have a lot to complain about
right now.
Things are going great,
but the eye,
my joke was,
I'm watching the show.
I go,
I admit I watch the show and I watch it
every day.
Hoping every day will be that day since
it's gonna happen,
you know,
you put your head in fucking crocodile's
mouth now.
And then when he died it was like a
funny joke.
Everyone used to laugh at it.
Then when he died,
my,
my agent over in Australia call me,
he goes,
mate,
you're fucked.
I go,
what?
He goes,
they're playing your clip on the radio.
And I was like,
oh no.
So they were playing it like these two,
like a discharge djs were playing at
this one station.
They thought it was kind of funny just
playing my bid over and over.
So I got.
I thought,
oh,
this is fucking.
I'm dead in America.
You know,
I would have been,
had gone into hiding.
Yeah,
me like,
mate,
you're fucking,
you're fucking champion.
May hilarious.
And I was like,
I want to go to Australia more.
These guys are fucking cool fun man.
You know what?
I love the color legend champion and a
legend that sit in england all the time.
Your legend,
the legend.
Your legend mate.
Alright,
speaking of legend,
before we get out of here,
I got it.
I found the bill o'reilly thing and I
got to read it because it's so
ridiculous.
Then when everything about bill
o'reilly,
no matter what you think about his
opinions,
this is what you need to know and this
is some,
some fucking voicemail that he left from
some woman.
Her name was andrea charisse and she
sued him for sexual harassment and this
is what he goes.
You would basically be in the shower and
then I would come in and you would have
your back to me and I would take the
loofa thing and kind of soap up your
back,
rub it all over you,
get you to relax hot water and um,
you know,
you'd feel the tension drain out of you
and you'd still be with your back to me.
And then I would kind of put my arm.
It's one of those myths,
one of those loofa mints,
you know,
so I got my hand in it and I would put
it around in front,
kind of rubbed your,
tell me a little bit within and then my
other hand would start to massage your
boobs,
get your nipples really hard because I
like that.
And you have really spectacular boobs.
So anyway,
I'd be rubbing your big boobs and
getting your nipples really hard,
kind of kissing your neck from behind.
And then the other right?
Yes it is.
And then I would take the other hand
with the falafel thing,
the falafels.
I don't know what that means and just
put it on your pussy and.
But you'd have to do it real light,
just kind of a tease business.
What a fucking goofy like any chick is
going to hear that and go,
oh yeah,
I was just thinking it was going to get
off on this shit.
Old broken people trying to romance her.
I'm like,
can I choke you?
And delirious jewish food.
Falafel apples.
Yeah,
middle eastern food.
But I don't think that's what he meant
was sloppy with some hummus and falafel
thing and that's not what you meant.
Chefs and cheap phase up here.
You just used the wrong word.
Maybe I dunno,
but that's it.
Understand that this is the kind of
human being you're dealing with and all
this shit that you see on the fucking in
the public guys.
Just nonsense.
You know?
It's just what we said before,
that people,
when they become famous and they get
adulation,
they start all of a sudden believing the
bullshit.
They believe their own hype.
It's step one to to losing it all like r
kelly and it's fuckin xuesong.
You got that bitch.
Yeah.
You want to play at the end.
We can cut it out the very end.
Yeah,
let's cue it up.
Cue it up and we'll play it at the very
end.
Do you know the angelica houston?
I think he heard that.
Said it.
She goes,
uh,
I go by the motto.
Never pick it up.
Never put it down.
Like,
if you don't take the adulation,
you can't take the criticism,
like focus on yourself.
Don't focus on like what other people
say.
And I try to do that because if I can
get on people,
but when you walk out of a show and
people,
you're great,
you're great.
What do you know?
That's just your opinion because you're
going to hear you suck too.
Right?
And so that way I don't take the.
You're great.
You're,
I just go.
Oh thanks.
But I don't let it soak in because
otherwise
what I like,
I like hearing we had a great time.
I don't want to hear your great.
I mean,
if you think that.
Thank you very much.
Um,
I'm trying,
I'm working hard.
Keep going.
I do it all for whoever likes to see the
comedy.
That's what I'm doing it for.
I mean that's you,
I think you,
you,
you alter your motivation as you get
older and as you get more successful and
as you kind of get a better
understanding of what you're doing.
Like as an artist.
And I think initially I just wanted to
get laughs.
I just wanted to,
for me,
I wanted to prove that I could be good
at this.
I wanted to get some success.
I wanted it,
I wanted to do it for me.
But then once you get the success,
then it has.
You have to change your,
your,
your rational or your um,
rather your motivation has to change and
it has to become,
in order to stay good and to stay
relevant you have to,
it has to become about the art.
You have to be obsessed with creating
good stuff.
You have to be obsessed with doing
something that people are going to
enjoy.
Those pops of brilliance when a new bit
comes to light in.
Did you go through a change though?
Because I remember like when I watched
you when I was younger and I was like,
oh I liked you because at that point in
my life I was into like island here,
like tits and ass and fucking pussy and
that's to me you were that kind of comic
and evening at the improv was guys with
their sleeves rolled up going what's the
deal with and you,
you're gone,
you know,
fuck that pussy and a while I was a
savage.
And then you think about how I got into
standup comedy.
I was a fucking kickbox.
But then you changed.
Now you do this kind of intellectual
type material that's like,
you know,
like what you talked about now.
Well when I was 21,
I'm still have a million dick jokes.
But when I was 21 I had nothing to say
about anything else.
I had no opinions.
I had no opinions on society.
I had no opinions on life.
I didn't think about religion at all
except it scared me because I went to
catholic school when I was little.
All I thought about when I was 21 and
was pussy,
that is all I was a fucking savage.
That's all I thought about.
I was here.
I was a former martial arts teacher and
fighter who is now a professional comic
and I was making my living working in
bars and doing standup and trying to
make girls like me.
I mean that's what I was doing.
Yeah.
And all I was obsessed with.
And all I was obsessed with was fucking.
And people would say that to me like
your act is all about sex and is your
act all about sex?
Um,
because I'm fucking 22 and my hormones
are blasting inside of my body,
like a broken fire hydrant,
slamming against the walls of my heart.
Like what are you talking about?
That's all I'm thinking about.
I don't know.
Anything else?
I had no opinions.
I could say sex jokes onstage and people
could laugh.
You know?
Why?
Because these are things that I was
actually thinking about.
So I had actual humorous points of view
on it and people would say,
well,
you're acting so dirty.
Well,
am I supposed to not talk about what I'm
obsessed with?
Should I talk about what you're obsessed
with?
I,
I guess I should have balanced.
It did go through a long time where,
you know,
especially if I do like a half an hour
set,
it was too much.
Sex talk was like,
it was like enough already,
dude,
you knew me,
you must have something else,
you know,
how many come shot jokes can you have,
but it's,
as I got older then I started,
you know,
looking at the world and you know,
then you know,
actually thinking about things and then
actually forming opinions and you know,
and it can deeply considering those
opinions before I ever thought about
taking them to the stage.
And then I had opinions about things for
years and years before I ever tried to
like put them in a humorous situation.
It's just a matter of developing as a
human being.
But you know,
as your motivation changes and as your
perception changes,
I mean it's just,
you,
you just mature,
you grow,
you think about things differently.
But as your audience,
your,
your ufc audience,
the guys that are like mma guys and like
that kind of stuff,
are they on the same mindset as you now
with your customers
cereal?
Or you'd be amazed,
first of all about ufc fans.
The first of all,
the broad spectrum of fence.
There's some fucking brilliant
intelligent ufc fans.
I've met some people in the mixed
martial arts business,
whether they're trainers or competitors
or you know,
people who just do it,
you know,
as a hobby or involved in a management
aspect.
Fucking brilliant people who are huge
fans of the sport,
you know,
I met a bunch of them are really like
the guys who own the ufc there.
Fucking smart people,
man.
They're not caveman.
I mean dana white's crazy and he swears
a lot stuff,
but he's a fucking really introspective,
like a very considerate and
compassionate person.
Like these guys like dana white recently
saved some Thailand girl.
There was a girl who needed to,
like,
I believe it was liver surgery and she,
she was the daughter of a trainer at
tiger moitai.
Somebody put a thread about it on the
underground and this girl is going to
die unless she gets this surgery within
the next eight weeks.
Dana white fucking paid for all of it.
You know,
he's like one of those guys.
He's not an asshole.
He's not a meathead,
you know,
he's a.
He's a really good dude.
Well I guess people that,
you know,
everybody looks at like cage fighting
fans and they think,
oh,
they must be assholes with skulls on
their shirts.
A lot of them are,
but a lot of martin and even in the
assholes with skulls and their shots,
they can be lead.
They can all be.
Everybody can look at things in a more
compact,
more fun,
friendly.
Well I'd imagine that like cage fighters
to themselves or kind of perfectionist
kind of guys.
And then like,
what was that thing?
I texted you one day and asked you about
the quote about if you can do one thing,
well you can do me a moto massage you.
That's why I got this tattoo.
See that shit is because I find sashi
versus a tiger like those that I do that
crossfit stuff and all the guys I do
crossfit with our obsessive compulsive
and very intellectual,
uh,
you find these guys are great athletes
and you would think they're just dumb
fucking,
you know,
can climb a rope and fucking power lift,
deadlift 500 pounds,
but you start finding out they know
everything about nutrition and then
everything about this and then it goes
to supplant transcendent.
People are not disciplined,
right?
Dumb people can work hard if they're
like in a football camp and the coach is
screaming at you every day or you know,
if you have to,
you know,
what you're in the army or something
like that.
But when you have to motivate yourself
to go to the gym and you have to
motivate yourself to buy the proper
nutrition and that takes intelligence,
it takes a certain amount of discipline.
Yeah.
So I've seen that these mixed martial
arts I've said,
because I would say that them,
the guys that,
that do fight and are really into it are
probably good fans that really get all
your material and,
and get into like the intellectual shit.
But I'm thinking like the average guy,
wwf foam and goes,
hey,
I just want to see some broken blood.
This.
Does he come to your show and be like,
don't be a dick joke.
There's that.
But you know what man,
I,
I make sure I try very hard to make sure
that my jokes are first and foremost
funny.
You know,
whatever my point of view is on
something.
It has to be,
it has to be digestible to a lot of
people.
But there's some weird shit that I might
think.
It's funny that if I had an audience
audience filled
with,
you know,
only like guys like you or dunk in or
someone who's like a very smart person
that's,
you know,
of a certain age.
I could talk to about almost anything I
would do different materials.
It was just you guys,
you know,
but to an audience full of a bunch of
people.
First of all,
I want everybody to have fun.
You know,
I want,
I want like a,
a julius fun,
festive atmosphere.
I want,
I wanted to be like an hour long party,
you know,
and the party filled with ideas and
thoughts and then you know that I'm not
coming from coming from a place of ego.
I'm not a egomania I'm,
I'm,
I'm calling for a place to just,
let's just figure this out.
Let's try to put this all together.
It's not me,
it's not about me.
It's about these ideas.
It's about fun.
It's about having a good goddamn time up
there.
So it's the ideas.
But I've got a lot of weird shit.
My act about time travel and the large
hadron collider and there's like,
there's some shit that,
there's some songs.
Sometimes when I'm on stage I go,
god damn,
I'm taking these motherfuckers don't
fucking twisty road here.
I hope there with me no hope there with
me when the punchlines come because
there might've been like,
you know,
after five minutes of large hadron
collider rant when I get to the end,
they're like,
what the fuck is he talking about?
You know,
people are taking notes.
I better go home and read about this
shit.
I think,
you know,
I initially I sort of,
did comedy just to try to get labs and
this is what I always say that there's
like a bunch of different stages of
comedy.
I think the first age that you do
anything you can to get a laugh,
you know,
I mean,
I'm sure you've said that some hacky
lines in your life that you're not lost
about.
I mean I look back the last time,
I think in 1997 or 90.
No earlier than that.
I was on newsradio though.
It was like 95,
96.
I told some woman,
hey,
I don't come to your job and slap the
dicks out of your mouth.
I can't believe I still use that.
Like in 90 I used it one time.
It was in montreal at the comedy works.
Some chick said something right after.
I said,
I'm like,
man,
really?
You didn't even dig into your bag.
You just grabbed the most obvious stupid
hacky law.
I still think about that to this day.
You know?
I think initially you're just trying to
get laughs and then once you get good
then it goes from what makes me laugh,
you know?
Instead of just trying to make anybody
laugh with like a tool,
like I have a hammer,
look at my hammer,
I'm going to hit the nail dong.
Then it becomes your perspective.
It's like becomes,
you know,
this is that,
this actually is funny to me,
and then it becomes how do you make
someone laugh with your opinions on
things like what,
what are your unique points of view that
you can somehow or another turn into
comedy.
So to me there's like been three stages
in my life.
The first stage was just say anything.
Even if you didn't believe in it.
I said a lot of stupid shit about,
about gay people,
about whatever the fuck I was,
if I thought it would work,
you know,
to me it was like,
is this a brick?
Can I kill a rat with it?
Let's kill her at,
you know,
it was just a tool.
I think I followed your model and I'm
just,
you know,
years behind you doing the same thing
where it's the analogy,
good analogy.
Hired was golf.
They said when you learn to golf,
just fucking hit the ball as far as you
can fucking hit it and then hone your
swing and bring it in instead of trying
to hit it right.
And then trying to hit it far so like
try to kill it first.
Try to learn how to kill and once you
kill you'll get all that confidence and
you'll never be scared and then hone it
in the good,
you know,
really creative,
interesting jokes with your point of
view.
But you can't go out there initially
with that.
Some guys probably have,
they try,
but they seem so pretentious and
especially when you're 20 and you're
breaking down the government police shut
the fuck up.
Yeah,
please go get hit in the head by a ball,
you know,
please get punched.
You know,
go,
go do something.
We develop some character to talk about
this off air.
Someone who does that.
Right.
I'm sure there's a lot of people will do
it.
Just,
you know,
you want to be somebody,
man.
You want to be.
Bill hicks,
you know is a great fucking lana
punchline.
One of the great clubs you ever worked
there.
One of the best jobs on country.
Fucking fantastic club.
Anyway,
the atlanta punchline has a,
a back room,
like a green room and it's got a bunch
of shit written on the wall and one
thing that I took a picture of a,
put it on my mobile log back when I had
a mobile log.
I've got to find it.
It must be on my.
It said it's quit trying to be hicks
fragment.
You started the at friend.
Oh,
okay.
Well go check that shit up.
It's just check this out,
joe,
read pancake,
pancake.net.
I don't think I need to see that,
but don't go to red pancake.net.
It's some sort of horrible venereal
diseases and poor fuck has.
And brian wants you to look at it.
Eddie f dot.
Where are you going to be next man?
I am in Australia.
Pretty much all a.
Yeah,
I got it.
We got a lot of australian people that
listen to the show.
So tell us where I'm doing the adelaide
fringe festival.
I'll be at the arts theater for 10
nights only.
And then I'm doing brisbane only 10
nights in a row.
Jesus christ.
I've never done 10 nights anywhere.
That's incredible.
Okay,
cool.
Four hundred 50 seats.
So start buying tickets.
Holy shit.
And then unpack places in Australia.
Huh?
It's going well.
I'm really happy.
Is that weird to be super famous in
another country?
I'm not super famous at all.
I mean are just super famous.
I'm at.
I'm happy with how it's going,
but I would like to see the same.
I told you yesterday I go,
it's not like I love Australia to great
fucking place.
I love to serve,
but you want to do the same thing here.
They just,
you know,
I like being around my family and I
want.
My parents did not think I'm a failure.
Holla at your boy.
So,
um,
what is your website?
Uh,
eddie ift,
ift.com.
And on twitter and it's eddie ifttt,
facebook.
I'm on facebook.
The facebook and facebook is easy to
find.
And our podcast is talking shit.
Yeah.
And your podcast.
Is it backup now?
It's,
if you google you will find it.
You don't have to go through itunes.
Everybody thinks you have to go through.
So libsyn,
libsyn,
available.
No matter what.
All the episodes are available and you
can get to libsyn,
I assume from eddie f.com.
And if you just took it down because of
the name,
they took it down a title.
Yeah.
In the titles.
And we fucked up and took it down from,
I guess I have to eat this guy's cunt.
Well they should've taken a down for
that.
Yeah,
we just do a podcast number one and he
actually had it done and I just have the
guests,
I understand their thing,
trying to keep children away from
explicit stuff and understand if we
fucked up,
we fucked up and they have a filter
though.
You think they would have some kind of
say they do and that's what they did.
They bumped us off or breaking the rules
and we just didn't know.
And so they killed all your feed and now
you have to get a whole new feed.
Yeah,
we're going to have to get a whole new
feel all your subscribers.
You have 35,000
subscribers for now.
We're going to lose all our subscribers.
So dan have to resubscribe.
So please folks go to itunes and
resubscribe.
Is it up now?
Is it?
I don't think it's up until tomorrow.
Okay,
go to [inaudible] dot com and download
it.
It's hilarious.
Eddie f this hilarious.
And jim jeffries is larry's too.
So the podcast is a fucking.
Can't miss you.
Dirty bitches.
A job's going to be there someday.
He's going to drive all the way to
venice and do our fucking shit.
I'm going to tell me when you,
we'll,
we'll work it out.
Tell me one maybe you heard it maybe
last week.
You guys around next week.
Monday,
tuesday,
wednesday.
Maybe we'll figure out next week.
I know I'm,
I was supposed to do tuesday with the.
What's that dude's name?
John lewis.
Joy from the league.
How do you say his name?
I think you said it right?
Least hilarious.
I'm his fucking songs on youtube or
genius and he's actually a fan of the
podcast and actually asked to be on.
I don't want to brag or anything but
he's coming on.
Um,
so he's,
he's going to be on next thursday so
maybe,
um,
maybe I'll do it someday.
Next week we'll figure it out.
venice talking shit.
And we'll,
we'll definitely put that shit on
twitter and let everybody know and we'll
try to get you guys back on itunes by
then.
And uh,
so that's it.
If you,
uh,
go to joe rogan.net
and click on the link for the flashlight
again,
the flashlight sponsored the show.
Thank you very much to them and you get
15 percent off if you type in the name
brogan this friday night.
I am at mandalay bay theater with Joe
Diaz and arusha fear.
Um,
it was a knock.
I'm getting some messages where people
are saying it's sold out,
but I don't know if that's true.
it was a very close though and it will
by the time showtime rules around which
is tomorrow night.
and then tonight,
uh,
ari shaffir has a storytelling show at
the improv and I'm going to go down and
fuck around there too.
So,
uh,
that's it for the show this week for
itunes.
And right after I say goodbye,
we're going to play this art kelly sung
was zoo because it's fucking ridiculous,
brilliant thing that's ever happened.
And exactly what we're talking about
when it comes to a celebrity turning
someone into a crazy person.
All right,
love you bitches.
Well,
on a key is full of free.